today was a disaster i mean the past
several days have been a disaster with
the us withdrawal from afghanistan first
and foremost i have long maintained as
many other libertarian personality types
even some conservatives and many
democrats have always said it was a
disaster to be in there in the first
place there was no good time we should
have left so
at the at the end of everything i'm glad
that we're finally leaving afghanistan
this is not the american nation-building
project or at least it wasn't supposed
to be
i think a lot of people got rich off of
it joe biden was one of the the
architects of the original invasion of
afghanistan in the first place
and i think right now we we've got to
acknowledge
at the very least
it would have been very different under
trump that doesn't mean there wouldn't
have been chaos that doesn't mean that
there wouldn't have been criticism but i
certainly think the bind administration
has proven to be extremely weak with
several disasters like the economy the
border i mean gas prices are through the
roof inflation is through the roof and
then you see this
when the disaster began unfolding where
was joe biden where was gensake on
vacation well biden came back briefly to
give a speech and actually a lot of
people are saying good things about it
and it's kind of ironic because of all
the things you could give credit to joe
biden for the last thing i thought
anybody would praise him for was
speaking
but it wasn't his ability to speak he
said some things i agreed with that
what are we going to do send us soldiers
to go fight a war the afghans don't even
want to fight themselves or what are we
going to do pass this off to the next
administration although it was uh uh
he didn't he like he tried to he tried
to take responsibility but also blamed
trump and blamed afghanistan so all
right i'm not gonna say too much we're
gonna get into all that and we'll talk
about it china's reaction has been i i
would say this is um
what's the right word
i don't know it should be taken as a
warning china's official state media
said when war breaks out with taiwan the
u.s will obviously not be able to do
anything to defend them they didn't say
if they said when so we're going to talk
about all this and i think there's some
nuance here i think there's a lot of
people who are being very tribal uh you
know looking for reasons to criticize
biden and i think there's tons of
reasons to criticize biden but i think
let's let's look i'm always going to
acknowledge someone doing something good
or saying something good we shouldn't be
in afghanistan we should withdraw he
could have stayed glad he didn't but
let's let's break down exactly what's
going on we've also got some stuff with
with inflation happening and i think
look guys obviously in the end bite into
disaster complete disaster but joining
us today is political commentator jassy
gestetner do you want to introduce
yourself yeah hi thanks uh tim for
having me my name is yasik stetner i
live up in new york and i've been a uh
political commentator
in the jewish community in new york
going back all the way to 2005
as a written columnist on a weekly basis
and also on a podcast through a phone
system believe it or not there are tens
of thousands of
observant jewish people who do not have
access to the internet at home
so they rely on a comprehensive phone
system which would serve as a podcast
for news information entertainment
and i've been blessed uh to be a
commentator there going back to 2007.
um and of course i like to be active on
twitter a couple of hours a day too much
but i think uh you know twitter's
interesting place to debate people um
and to hear ideas and to get a message
out there so that's what i do in the
political arena in terms of commentary
right on you had some good tweets about
biden so we'll get into all that stuff
too yeah we also got idea kind of feels
like
a mix between christmas night and like
we're celebrating this whole iraq
pull-out thing and september 11 2001 uh
i was in new york and after the
buildings came down we all got together
out and had lunch and it was like the
most
dazing disorienting chaotic
feeling and i kind of feel like a mix
between that and christmas right now
with this iraq thing it's it's
it's in afghanistan yeah
[Laughter]
get us out of iraq yeah i mean
it is it is a good point because on the
one hand i think people are glad to see
that the us is moving on from
afghanistan in terms of having
boots on the ground but uh you know the
images
being a complete disaster is something
which
is you know will live in infamy so i
think that's the contradiction between
being a joyous time and a concerning
time yeah yeah there's something
interesting there's also some
interesting media stuff and uh media
manipulation stuff i noticed in the
changes to the uh wikipedia entries to
the taliban which i think have political
significance so we'll talk about the uh
talk about that too we got lydia
pressing i'm pressing buttons in the
corner i'm intrigued by what happened
this weekend and i'm really interested
in what we figure out tonight
before we get started though my friends
we have an awesome sponsor today head
over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
biotrust's ageless multi-collagen we
have it right here ian actually just
puts some in his coffee it's really good
stuff it's uh it's unflavored you mix it
right in and collagen is what makes your
skin your joints your bones everything
stronger the other day i was skating
down in the mini ramp and i kept taking
a bunch of knee slides what that means
is like you're you're going up the half
pipe you fall and then you land on your
knees and i thought to myself like dude
i'm old i i better start eating better
and taking care of myself i started
eating a lot better recently it's been
great exercising a lot more and i still
skate every day but i'm like we got to
up it we got to do more we got to eat
better and this is part of it this
biotrust ageless multi-collagen is
really really awesome i also bought knee
pads which because that just seems to be
smart but check it out go to
strongerbonesandlife.com you'll get a
60-day money-back guarantee you'll get
the the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms the five key
types that you need from four different
sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits for every order
today biotrust will donate a nutritious
meal to a hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 5 million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 6
million meals this year it's non-gmo
it's free of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners it's free
of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbst
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements it
almost adds like a fullness to it like
it's like a creaminess kind of i don't
know is that what you would say yeah
yeah it's like a quickening agent sort
of interesting now here's the best part
first of all free shipping but you also
get free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
the 14 foods for amazing skin with every
order biotrust thank you so much for
sponsoring the show go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you'll get
51 off but don't forget go to
timcast.com be a member we got a whole
bunch of amazing journalism and we're
gonna have a bonus segment uh
members-only segment coming up around 11
pm or so we do that monday through
thursday so make sure you check that out
support our work but uh uh let's get
into the news before we get started
again just smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share it with
your friends that that does it for our
introductory plugs let's talk about
what's going on in afghanistan and the
first thing i want to address is i was
shocked by uh the news
when when joe biden started giving his
speech and uh i was watching it i was
shocked to see how many people were
actually praising him i mean notably my
friend cassandra fairbanks when she said
it was a good speech not that it's
absolving him of responsibility of his
failures but at the very least look i
got to say this he said a few things i
really did like and i think the
important thing about it why i'm going
to say thank you for saying these things
notably
we can't send americans to fight a war
the afghans are not willing to fight
themselves we were not supposed to be
nation-building in afghanistan we cannot
pass this on to the next president and
we can't send another generation of our
men and women in uniform to go into this
quagmire this waste of money those are
good things because it vindicates a lot
of the anti-war positions of democrats
conservatives libertarians basically
everybody who've been saying the same
thing finally you get the president to
come out and say it that doesn't mean
he's done a particularly good job with
the withdrawal in fact a lot of people
are kind of shocked at how bad and
disastrous it was
surprisingly you know as i said earlier
i said in the intro the one thing that
he's getting praised for is the one
thing probably no one ever expected
actually speaking to be fair though not
everybody is giving him praise a lot of
people are saying that
it was a mixed bag he was blaming trump
he said well i inherited this deal it's
not my fault and the afghans are the
ones who don't want to fight but the
buck stops with me it's like all right
we'll just come out and say that you
made the decision i think ultimately it
was the right decision to leave
obviously bad things are happening but
uh you know with that i can i can
respect that we're getting out of uh
afghanistan rossi you had you had
similar tweets i think you were yeah my
the point that i'm trying to make over
the past 36 hours is you know people who
are pushing around blame under
withdrawal i don't think the debate is
if the u.s should leave or not the
question is um
why abandon the place again most of my
commentary over the last 16 years has
been on
uh politics
here at home economics and the politics
of politics like i wouldn't
say that i'm that i have expertise in in
the military field but just you know
following a little bit with people
trying to push around blame between
trump and biden
um you know everyone says well trump had
a a plan to leave okay so there's a plan
to leave mean that we'll have this
disaster
my guess is that if trump were president
and the taliban were advancing over the
last few weeks he would pop off ten
tweets a day tell them one more step
these guys are making will drone them
and he would probably unleash hellfires
on them too hellfire missiles
and they would probably stop their
advancement
um
you know the us for the last couple of
years had only um
last year so i think had only two and a
half thousand soldiers in afghanistan
and the peace was kept why is that it's
because people understood people on the
ground understood
that
the afghan government is underwritten by
the us underwritten by the u.s doesn't
mean the u.s needs to have
20 30 000 troops it means that the u.s
is there to give air support intel and
to take care of the bad guys
the problem here is not the withdrawal
it's abandoning the place as i said if
trump were in i think we would probably
see from him dozens of tweets every day
going back a couple of weeks
warning them that one you know if they
go one more kilometer he'll smoke them
and he would probably smoke some of
these guys and they would stop
so yeah i agree so yeah i don't think
the
you know i think michael tracy his name
is uh yeah so he yeah so he he made the
point that well uh any withdrawal would
be a disaster it would be difficult
i don't know we had a two and a half
thousand troops and now we have we sent
back seven to clean up the mess again i
i have no
expertise in military but work but uh
seems strange so i don't think every um
defense department or every
administration would necessarily execute
uh something you know this is this is
what kind of bums me out is you know joe
biden saying some of those those things
that i mentioned i'm like thank you for
saying that for america to hear because
now it's like what was that about ron
paul oh he was right what's that about
those who are who are opposed to this
war they were right but in the end it
just feels like
they're sitting in the in and they're
sitting in the you know a room going in
a meeting like what do we do how do we
address the american people and
someone's like i'm going to say whatever
they want to hear because we screwed
this up
i i but i want to say i agree with you
trump would have been bombing him he
would have he would i think correct i
think trump in in office would have
probably preserved some of the gains
in other words
the damage of the way this withdrawal
was done is the way it was done
uh it's not preserving what you have and
i don't think you need necessarily
troops on the ground to preserve it
the understanding was
i think we can we can walk it back a
little bit to may the official deal was
that the us is going to leave in may why
didn't the taliban pop off in may why
did they wait until now
obviously there were some either
understanding on the ground or movement
by the us
that the taliban decided now it's time
to move so the u.s with a couple of
thousands of troops on the ground was
able to hold back the taliban from may
till now
which means they're probably they were
probably able to do that going forward
with some sort of a not even a
contingent of troops but again drones
or just being there and saying we are
going to defend this government and
don't dare make any moves i think people
would listen as they did i think the the
the main issue is that it's biden you
know look obviously the taliban china
all these other countries china's making
fun of us we'll pull that up in a little
bit
they can see that we've got an economic
disaster we've got a border crisis we
had leaked audiotapes of majorca saying
you know we can't sustain the border
it's a disaster and effectively saying
we're going to lose control of this
and then you look at joe biden calling
uh you know uh shutting down press
events like not showing up going on
holiday
people are criticizing them constantly
gensaki's on vacation the taliban have
been seeing everything's been happening
with this and they're probably thinking
this administration is too weak to do
anything
now is there opportunity so i think with
trump like you're right he had been
tweeting like a madman and i definitely
think
for better or for worse trump was viewed
by a lot of people around the world with
disdain and fear because he was kind of
erratic he was kind of he was extremely
arrogant and aggressive and so you had
this this you know it's kind of a
negative of character right
but when you when you realize what that
means for the taliban they're thinking
this guy's insane because yeah i think
yeah i think trump strategically decided
you know the whole world is is shivering
every time kim jong-un is going to do
something trump figured well i can be
kim jong-un times over because i'm the
u.s we have a bigger military bigger
budget big it means so if everyone stops
oh you know this madman is going to go
crazy you know what let me play the same
game again i haven't spoken to him but
just against the way he behaved so what
i'm saying is
withdrawing with this disaster just
means as as china said you know that
people in hong kong or taiwan whatever
should know that the us is not going to
be there and and that's a distinction i
think we've we've been saying that about
taiwan for a minute that uh with the
escalation of rhetoric with you know uh
china sent in uh aircraft into the
taiwanese defense airspace
i'm i'm saying
baiden's going to do nothing i mean that
mark milly i i think but let me but let
me ask you who who has appetite for it
for for for yeah to to the u.s to take
on china i mean if diaz wants to take on
china china's main uh i would say
objective but the main tool that they
use is
economics they keep keep on investing in
in other countries they buy a property's
infrastructure they they lend money to
countries
we are busy you know i don't know
playing games here at home so
we we can pin it again i just want to
you know challenge a little bit of
thinking that biden wouldn't do but who
would do and who who would back it you
don't think trump would have lost his
mind and sent in a bunch of military i
think i i think there's there was a
smaller chance
of china doing something against taiwan
with trump than it is with biden or
someone else but again i'm not making
any military predictions i'm saying if
you look at china the last 20 30 years
their main objective around the globe i
think they even have deal with uh they
had to deal with afghanistan or pakistan
they have
i think they're announcing support for
the taliban correct they have support
all over the place and and in the u.s
you didn't have
most people weren't even with trump on
the issue of
uh balancing out uh tariffs and and uh
important export i wanna i wanna i wanna
uh pull up biden's speech because i
think we as much as we can be happy that
he said things we gotta call out the
criticism and we gotta we gotta hold him
to his word right so let me just read a
couple a couple things he said when it
came into office i inherited a deal that
president trump negotiated with the
taliban under this agreement u.s force
would be out of afghanistan by may 1st
2021 just a little little over three
months after i took office
u.s forces had already drawn down during
the trump administration from roughly 15
500 american forces to 2500 troops in
the country and the taliban was its
strongest military since 2001. the
choice i had to make as your president
was either to follow through in that
agreement or be prepared to go back to
fighting the taliban in the middle of
the spring fighting season there would
have been no cease-fire there would be
no agreement protecting our forces after
may 1st there was no status quo
stability without american casualties
after may 1st there was only a cold
reality of either following through on
the agreement to withdraw our forces or
escalating the conflict and sending
thousands more american troops back into
combat in afghanistan and lurching into
a third decade of conflict i stand
squarely behind my decision after 20
years i've learned the hard way that
there was never a good time to withdraw
us forces that's why we're still there
we were clear-eyed about the risks we
planned for every contingency but i
always promised the american people that
i'll be straight with you
the question i have is as he goes on to
talk about american troops cannot and
should not be fighting in a war and
fighting uh in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight themselves does that apply to
every other country that the u.s has
military bases in does that apply to
syria should should we should we be
there if bina wants to come out and say
these things that are going to be ear
candy to people who are anti-war i want
to see him actually put up and follow
through
and then yeah i mean the us has what uh
25 000 troops in in the korean peninsula
and uh so
if if biden's stance is that the the
country locally isn't willing to uh put
up a fight and therefore we should leave
then i guess the u.s can save a lot of
money uh yeah withdraw from korea from
you know from from any player from japan
whatever you know it's it is yeah it is
in south korea whatever
it's it's it's an interesting point uh
that's why i don't think it's serious i
think what happened is
they inherited this deal
and i think they hate that they did i
think you know if trump didn't negotiate
the withdrawal because the american
people wanted it i guess what was it
like trump came in on like day three or
whatever and told all these people we're
getting out of afghanistan we're done
with this i can't remember who told us
that and i think they were they were mad
about it but i think biden did realize
trump drew down our forces to a degree
we're gonna follow through but man did
they not plan for this i gotta i gotta
say it they extended the timeline by
three months
clearly did not use that three months
for planning because the question
everybody has is why didn't they disable
the american military equipment why
didn't they blow it up or burn it or
destroy it because they didn't do it all
these months because they were under the
illusion that afghan military is a legit
force and they'll use it
that's the problem
uh but
but i think but the counter argument
that is okay that's why they didn't blow
up blow it up two or three weeks ago but
why not over the last few days just blow
everything up if you're anyway dealing
with a bunch of clowns you know yeah the
taliban doesn't have an air force i
guess now they do
and they could have uh just droned like
gotten rid of there's a meme going
around saying they got 166 blackhawks i
don't know if it's true but they were
like more than many other countries just
gave these these people these weapons
like yeah but i think yeah i think in
terms of military equipment uh you know
every year the there is the defense
authorization bill i think the last one
was 787 billion dollars both parties in
washington are willing to continue
continue to spend on military hardware
military infrastructure
and there isn't any accountability in
other words accountability not if if a
defense contractor charges two dollars
more than they should per item it's just
like
who who decides like and who who who who
is accountable to whom when a certain
amount of humvees or apache helicopters
are sent overseas remember remember that
photo of isis driving around that truck
that had like some american business
printed on the side of it gm i think
no no no no it's like a local plumbing
service yeah i can't remember exactly
what it was but it was like how did that
truck end up in the middle like what is
this i think a white pickup or something
yeah yeah something weird like that
normally they'll use nano thermite to
decommission vehicles when they're not
using anymore it's a military-grade
incendiary that'll melt the vehicle from
the inside yeah but in this case it's
like hey now they have some some
vehicles that we can figure out how to
destroy by building new weapons and now
we can
fund uh you know lockheed to do that
let's talk about the um
the political manipulation of
information let's call it that this
morning when i was reading about the
news and uh just going over general
fact-checking and stuff i came across uh
i'm i was fairly certain i was reading
somewhere on wikipedia
that the taliban was estimated in 2017
to have 200 000 soldiers which is a
massive number and that means there was
a massive increase in the size of the
taliban during the obama biden
administration specifically because
their numbers were substantially lower
around 2008 or so so they went up from
like you know 18 thousand to fifty
thousand to two hundred thousand by 2017
well that would imply that donald trump
before he came in office inherited this
co inherited this conflict in
afghanistan that was untenable two
hundred thousand taliban that's a crazy
number
well we were doing research for this uh
for for this show and i was like i want
to pull that up and talk about that
that's a really interesting see like
who's really at fault here i mean
biden's president now but he was vice
president you know for for eight years
when this problem was happening so i
google searched here's what you find
when you google search taliban size in
2017. it says in 2017 the taliban was
estimated to have 200 000 troops and
that's the wikipedia entry for the
taliban however if you actually go that
entry has been removed and they've
changed i'll just go right in they've
changed the year check this out to 2021.
now look at that that's really
interesting because you know why why
those years and why remove that source
and then say 200 000 in 2021 well in my
opinion
it changes responsibility
if you're saying that in 2014 there were
60 000
uh taliban
you're basically implying that under
donald trump the taliban massively grew
in size
yet when you google search it it said
2017. so which is it honestly i don't
know for sure
the sources have changed and i'll tell
you this
everybody is going to try and use that
to point the blame at the other side but
i i do think it's fair to say
obama biden had eight years of this
trump came in put in a deal to shut it
down i'm glad it's finally over i can
say that i don't know if you guys what
your thoughts are on the on the numbers
yeah i i don't uh i don't know who who
keeps count on the taliban count uh on
taliban numbers if it's intelligence
community they were saying a couple of
days ago that
kabul can hold the taliban push for 90
days and it held like for 90 minutes 90
hours so
isn't it crazy to think that they have
200 000 i'm wondering if they change the
way that they measure who's in the
taliban or not like they do with the
census
like how like obama did when he started
killing civilians right like it could be
any non-american yeah like i saw i saw a
tweet i think um
i forgot who it was he said that any red
tape
any refugee red tape from afghanistan
needs to be removed and we need to
welcome in uh you know refugees
so i wrote what's the process for the
u.s to protect against former taliban
members who will then claim their
refugees it's not like
the u.s has a database database of
exactly everyone who was part of the
tolerance so i think a lot of these
numbers whether they're more or less i
think it's just guesses uh estimates
which
um if it's from intelligence community
it's potentially uh flawed as we have
seen many things
uh that they estimate about afghanistan
uh being totally flawed so the source
for the wikipedia that says 200 000
is in january now here's the funny thing
al jazeera the taliban explained they
say on the 25th of july 2021 an updated
on august 15th
they mentioned oh scroll right down the
group is believed to have 85 000
full-time fighters across the country
and exert control over more than half
the country's roughly 400 districts why
isn't this article which is
newer used as the source on wikipedia
because why was the data changed it's
good propaganda baby that's a lot of
taliban makes us look like the good guys
isn't it crazy to think that we're in an
information i'm not going to say one is
writer i'm sure someone will make their
argument they'll be like oh well that
was an official report you know from you
know a military contractor or from the
government this is al jazeera and then
someone could argue well al jazeera's
got resources in the region they
certainly have better access to the
information and they're going to know
better everyone's going to argue but
i'll tell you this we are we are
constantly in the middle of
propagandistic warfare it is
it's a horrible reality of of the world
we live in
you know we we used to have tv
commercials now it's constantly they're
they're changing history you know the
news breaks it looks bad for obama so
they had four years hey the estimate two
hundred thousand they removed the 2017
number and now now it seems like trump
again who is like
who is looking at afghanistan as a
project in the in the through the
perspective of whether it's a bomb or
not i think the average person who
follows the news
zooms out for a moment says you know
what 20 years there's been many
presidents and even biden you know biden
didn't come in as someone saving today
he was a senator for i don't know how
many years that afghanistan was going on
and then he was vice president so he
wasn't an onlooker
he was there for most of the time so i
think
the typical person who follows the news
a little bit thinks of afghanistan as a
as a total mess all around this party
that party it doesn't matter it's like
it's a mess and i think people are left
scratching their heads okay we had their
only two and a half thousand uh soldiers
there for a while now
and the piece held so what happened now
that everything went to hell in the
handbasket
uh i think i think just from a practical
perspective not necessarily political
people would want to want to wonder that
rather than exactly when it went up or
down might be it was costing us 40
billion a year uh recently up to now
like a couple trillion since we went in
two trillion i think so maybe it's just
like bankrupt times because of kovitz
the economy's not doing too we gotta cut
costs
i gotta say i really love uh the the
meme post where it's like uh the school
children in afghanistan and and all of
these establishment dems are like
these poor school children now can't go
to school and the girls are running home
and then someone comments none of them
are wearing masks
like where's the priority for
afghanistan for these kids or whatever
not that i think that's actually the
main priority yeah you want to use an
interesting number um
a couple of months ago when people
debated handing out another two thousand
dollars in stimulus
the democrats wanted
two thousand dollars per family or
something and mitch mcconnell was
willing to give only um
six hundred dollars this was a big fight
before the georgia runoffs
if you take 40 billion dollars
and you give it hand it out to americans
1400 more you can actually give it to 28
million
american households you can give this 40
billion so
mitch mcconnell was willing to sign off
on all these big
military spending bills every year
and this is just uh 40 billion for
afghanistan
and he wasn't willing to spend money
there it's just interesting how people
decide the priorities of politics
yeah and it's interesting i think i
think the important thing to point out
is
the establishment republicans and
democrats were all in on this it was
you know like i think it's silly to play
these games you've got people saying
blame trump on twitter it's virally
trending you've got people saying you
know bidens crisis or whatever i do
think it's fair to say like biden's the
president you know i i we don't know
what trump would have
what would have happened we can
speculate i certainly think there would
have been problems he would have been
criticized but i think you look at what
he did with like sulaimani and he would
have been
you know you've been dropping bombs on
on the taliban yeah but the question is
in a year or two from now um
how would people view
the u.s moving on from afghanistan will
they
view it as
will they remember the the the few days
of crisis now or will they say oh you
know what we were there for 20 years now
we're gone and everything's good i think
it's going to be real negative i think
it's going to be a a smear on the body
administration in a very very bad way
for him i think it's going to be used by
republicans relentlessly but i do think
a lot of regular people are going to say
both parties were involved both parties
take responsibility
to be fair though i think the trump uh
base and trump himself are only you know
they're they're not really republicans
in the in the traditional sense you know
trump was an insurgent candidate the
republicans didn't like him they didn't
like him when he was president and even
now you've got the established
republicans you've got the populist
republicans making up a smaller uh batch
of those running in 2022.
ultimately i think
we can look back to 2000s we can look
back to all the mistakes that were made
i think in the end a lot of people are
just going to say i'm glad it's over
with but we're going to see a lot of
news about what's going to be happening
in afghanistan that's true after this
it's going to be
you know women are already wearing
burqas like literally a day later and
you see all the men even you even have
the reporters you know that closer award
from cnn she's wearing the burka now she
she is saying if the meme isn't correct
that she made this dramatic change she
always wore a headscarf but now she's
wearing the more you know what she's
saying yeah she wrote she's she's
wearing something more and as i wrote on
twitter you know it's interesting how
some reporters i'm not saying she
specifically they are
you know they have the
self-proclaimed guts to go after the
pro-religious states here in the u.s but
when they're overseas they they respect
religion or whatever you know if you
want to respect religion
on whichever level it is then you know
you should do that do that at home too
and not pile on to indiana or texas or
what have you
i think in the coming months we are
going to see some really awful imagery
out of afghanistan uh i think
a lot of people in the establishment are
going to try and use it to justify why
we should have stayed why we shouldn't
have withdrawn and i think a lot of
people i think it's gonna actually i
take that back i take that back what i
wanna say is i think there's gonna be
news available but i wonder if the media
is actually gonna show it because it
will reflect extremely poorly on joe
biden whether whether you believe it's
his fault or not he's the president and
people are going to say the biden
administration and afghanistan i didn't
i think it's going to be really bad for
him uh you know what we don't have is a
lot of video of the war itself which we
had in vietnam was all the video on the
ground with the troops dudes getting
their legs blown apart guys you know
screaming for their mother and falling
down on punji sticks you know the terror
the horror and in in afghanistan we
didn't get to see it they didn't they
opted out so we get the doors getting
kicked in little kids getting mowed down
we don't get to see that stuff we so now
we now they're going to imaginarize us
with this
we just end this i'm sorry tim no no no
sorry i was i just wanted to just
address one point you made is that we do
have a lot of images out of afghanistan
we've we've long had that but relative
to vietnam after vietnam they realized
we got to stop putting our media on the
ground with the troops because they're
seeing too much of the horror and we're
not going to get our wars if we don't or
potemkin rides you know yeah security
iraq war they did a potemkin ride
through the desert with for abc media
everything's great look at how look at
look at somebody
then there's also i think i think uh
things were relatively stable in the
last few years in afghanistan in terms
of the us u.s uh casualties and so forth
uh yeah we've our tech is more advanced
that's correct so so it it isn't it
isn't the vietnam era but i get your
point yeah yeah we don't see the
americans dying but we also don't see
the the afghani kids getting getting it
either if they're if
if they really wanted to make this
project or whatever they were doing work
you'd have to be there for a hundred
years you would have to
uh raise generations but i i i i won't
get finished no no i'm saying i'm trying
to understand i'm
not too you know just to ask a question
the u.s
figured after world war ii that they
need to stay long term
in
many of these places i don't think
things were perfect the day after the
war probably there were some casualties
and issues
so from a policy perspective if the u.s
was able to keep the peace relatively
okay with just a few thousand troops not
even being so active on the ground
what's the problem with that i mean you
still have troops today in germany
obviously not because to keep the peace
there but just it illustrates the point
where for many years um yeah east german
germany and west yeah the berlin wall
came up in in 1960 or the late 1950s it
wasn't right after
uh world war ii which finished in 45
so obviously any place where things are
so rocky and so destructive it probably
takes many many years to have some sort
of an outside
for a peacekeeping force or something so
i understand people became tired from
afghanistan but
considering that the u.s kept the peace
there now with such a small amount of
troops why jump now
again i'm trying to figure it out it's
economic i think i don't know because it
costs so much money well i think a lot
of people uh trump supporters especially
don't want our troops in germany donald
trump gets a big big hand for this i
have a lot of complaints but he was
adamant about getting us out of iraq he
drew us down and he was on a course he
drew down the forces and therefore biden
comes in and does what what's the
connection between that and biden's
decision now then what happened brighton
said he thought what did he that he
can't go back on the deal
yeah because it would just mean the
taliban is massively powerful and we
don't have enough troops to actually
stage combat so we better just get him
out i mean trump trump laid the uh laid
the groundwork
and you know what a lot of people i i'm
not a fan of the us being the world
police i like the idea that
i'll put it this way when i play
civilization i don't go around
conquering nations and that's how i play
i play to to to strengthen and make the
world make life better for the people of
my country the idea that the us could
keep just going spending money in places
like afghanistan to try and build
nations
i'm not a fan of that i'm not a fan of
the us having troops in in germany for
that matter i mean world war ii has long
been over are we really concerned about
europe can't they provide for their own
defense yeah so in terms of if it if
being in afghanistan was the issue of
being there was mostly a monetary
decision then what about uh whatever
amount of thousands of troops in korea
or in europe
what's the rationale for that i agree
maybe that we're not building
we're not building land in those other
countries obviously yeah obviously they
were safer there you didn't have you
know any troops here and there when you
know going into harm's way they were
just you know training there living
there
so i'm not saying it's the same thing
i'm asking this from both ways on the
one hand if you look in the the war in
in after korea
in the 1950s 1953 or you look in europe
after 45 the u.s has troops on the
ground to train
so
why not do it in other places on the
other hand if in terms of cost so if you
went out of afghanistan due to cost then
get out of korea and europe too there's
a big difference uh world war ii you had
after world war ii you had the soviets
obviously we split germany in half and
then you uh and then with the rise of
the soviet union their expansion you had
vietnam vietnam and korea the idea there
was stop the expansion of communism i'm
not saying i agree with any of that
stuff but i don't know what would have
happened the idea i suppose to try and
play dev's advocate would be
if you don't stop the spread of
communism and they keep taking more and
more countries eventually it will be
impossible to stop the rise of this this
authoritarian system that murders you
know hundreds of millions
so the u.s says we're going to engrave
engage them in proxy wars and defend you
know korea and vietnam they fail we you
know we failed in vietnam korea is
effectively a you know 60 or whatever
yeah yeah stalemate
and then eventually the soviet union
collapses anyway so i don't know if the
u.s you could say the u.s succeeded in
stopping the expansion of communism
which ultimately fell
but what about afghanistan has anything
to do with
that giant threat
in other words yeah because if it's
because if it's uh if it's a uh a
military threat you know the military
hardware that the u.s has these days
uh by uh sending in a uh strike team or
or droning something or someone i think
uh it's not the same
it's it's an interesting point after
world war ii they did the liberal
economic order they set up like the
world police from 1946 they though
england united states france decided
we're going to set up a global military
force to prevent world war iii they call
it the liberal economic order that's
where they started building all these
military bases and they set up a world
of limited war and henry kissinger for
instance is a huge proponent but i think
we've eclipsed the age of limited war it
no longer makes sense and it no longer
makes sense to have all our troops in a
centralized spot they're too vulnerable
we we do our things from drones from far
away so so so i think you can cut back
from korea even more and then come home
from europe i wanna i gotta play this
video guys you gotta see this video
that's going viral and i gotta be honest
i think it's fake i i honestly think
this video is fake
um
it's a video i'm gonna play it for those
that are listening i'll try to explain
it where you see a man in uniform i
gotta be honest like it looks real but i
just can't believe it
there is a man in uniform with a bunch
of afghan security forces doing jumping
jacks and one guy can't figure out how
to do a single jumping jack you you jump
and you clap your hands and you put your
hands down and he's like going like this
and he's shuffling around the the the
military guy he looks like an american
soldier just like
almost gives up
watching this video of these guys
not be able to do jumping jacks the
tweet is just it's from some uh from
some user tweeting to uh jeremy uh
boring we tried to train them i said how
the f is this real what the f were we
doing in afghanistan they're not even
jumping jacks have you seen the video no
they're not they're not doing jumping
jacks like the one guy does like a weird
shuffle and they're it's like i don't i
don't understand you know watching this
guy try to explain to them and just be
completely exasperated
it's it's insane i could not imagine
trying to deal with creating a military
out of people who can't do a jumping
jack now i don't blame the people of
afghanistan this is not their world they
who who was it was it forest who told us
they believed the americans came to
fight dragons was that forest who told
us he didn't tell me that he might have
told you that i wasn't there on the show
no i don't know was it i don't know who
said this someone said something about
there's like a mythology that some of
the the the farmers had because they
didn't know anything about politics or
worldly affairs and so when this when
the troops were coming they thought it
was to like fight dragons in the
mountains or something like that
i mean i mean north korea
has been telling their public for many
years that the rice and whatever food
that the u.s is sending
is to compensate for the war in the 50s
so you know you never know you know
you never know what you know what local
governments tell their people i i just i
saw that video and i'm like
we should have left a long time ago yeah
as soon as someone in command saw that
video they said all right let's uh wrap
it up we'll pack it in these people
can't do jumping jacks
what kind of conflict are they expecting
to win
it was it that's why i was saying before
if the u.s really did or whoever you
know wanted this the
military contractors if you want this to
succeed we have these photos
little girls and boys going to school
we have the the afghani girls science
team and engineering team and stuff we
have this this is really famous skate
video of a little girl skateboarding in
afghanistan
if you wanted that to survive you would
have to stay in the country for a
hundred years
and you'd have to constantly fight the
taliban
and i think they realized it's just not
possible or it's just an extreme cost
because what would happen is here's what
we see did you see those videos and
photos coming out of afghanistan now
almost as bad as the jumping jack video
military age men
desperately fleeing full speed
hanging on the side of airplanes
horrifying imagery loading up the c-17
why didn't they want to stay and fight
for
what they had
because there was no social cohesion so
one of the big mistakes i guess the us
and the contractors made is there was no
culture
the only culture that existed was people
who live in afghanistan and then say
what should i do americans like
basically just deferring to them with
the americans gone they're like we don't
know what we have or what we're fighting
for or why
there may be there is no national
pride international unity there it's
like just things all over the map um
on a sectarian basis
um
people who are
you know
shia muslims or sunni muslims i'm not
many of the countries many of the
countries uh around the world uh
you know were created when was it 70 80
80 years ago based on religion religious
lines more than anything it's because
you didn't have any um
what do you call it a national pride if
you will
you know
what are the values of your country
just because uh
i live here and someone decided to make
a border there doesn't mean that i
associate with the person
living 10 miles up a story
that's what the people of afghanistan
lacked
and you know the u.s is losing it too
when we see like the 6019 project in
critical race theory i i saw these
videos i see these people
running and trying to get on airplanes
to leave this country and i'm like why
wouldn't they stay and fight for their
country because they have nothing to
believe in
there's no great story of the evil that
was that they triumphed over there's no
great tale of revolution how the people
chose their will it's just literally the
u.s came here told us what to do and i'm
going to school and now it's like oh
with the taliban coming back in
i'll just leave because there's no
reason for me to stay here it's almost
like
all america was able to do was to create
a hollow shell of a country or at least
what they thought was a country i guess
there are stories now of uh but but to
challenge this
i mean obviously the people who joined
the taliban do feel something for
afghanistan no right obviously the muji
hadin back in the 80s who fought back
russia felt for afghanistan
so right there is something there uh you
know sadly it's only the side of
radicalism extremism
but
i think there's something there but on
the other hand there are things lacking
that's what the u.s didn't understand in
this that you needed to give a story you
needed people needed to have a shared
story of the triumph or whatever it is
they were resisting
but it wasn't delivered and i don't know
if it's possible i don't know if it's
possible to instill like a great story
and teach kids i guess the problem is
after 20 years there should have been a
generation of young men being like i i i
believe in this i i learned these things
but they didn't learn any values they
didn't learn any philosophy or ideology
all they learned was yeah yeah in 20
years 20 years is a literal generation
that's the generation you've got 20 year
olds people are 20 years old today 18
year olds these are these are fighting
age males
i don't necessarily blame them the us
did a stupid thing but do we like the
taliban no already women are back in
burkas the schools apparently the little
reports the little girls are running
running back home they can't go to
school anymore that's horrifying the
thing that's going to be imposed on
these people and i think it's the
important i think the important lesson
here that every american needs to
understand is if you lose social
cohesion if you lose a
a community identity like what it means
to be
an american why you like this country
what you believe in and what you're
willing to stand up for and i think we
are losing that eventually nobody fights
they flee
absolutely i think it comes down to the
fact that you cannot give someone
something and expect them to take as
good of care of it as they would if they
had earned it themselves um this is uh
true on the personal level and i think
it's 100 if not even more true on like
the national level so when you give the
afghani people um if you give the
afghani people something and expect them
to take care of it they're like well i
didn't have any part in this i don't
have any investment in this there's no
reason for me to fight for this i got a
better analogy and i'm walking down the
street in chicago
no one will ever give you a free cd
that's not true people do but most
people don't you know why what happens
when a guy's like hey man you want my cd
well not my money after that no they've
people throw in the garbage oh no
oh yeah cool man it's a it's a buck and
it's already in your hand you're like
they can give it to me dude right they
hand it to you and they're like okay one
dollar the funniest thing is they they
still do this in some places even though
i have a cd player but the point is 10
years ago because i'm an old man they
they
nobody wants to give you free music in
fact i had a lot of people uh in the
industry would say
those guys it's exactly why they don't
sell it you don't value it if it's
handed to you you have to give something
and then value what you exchanged
exactly but but uh the u.s did spend a
lot of time to train people you know
gave them a force so to speak they
couldn't do jumping jacks bro
i want this video
if these people are like
from an era of really bad food and water
and they just don't have the intellect i
i don't think it's food and water i
think it's these are older guys they
look like they're probably in their late
20s to 30s
and they've never lived in this world
like imagine if if someone came to you
right now ian and said you know they
want they wanted you to be a boxer
someone would be like okay do it show me
your jab you'd be like yeah do a dance
step and then they show you the dance
stuff oh put it this way they'd be like
how could you not do a jab what do you
put in this way imagine imagine uh since
you're 10 years old i don't know how old
you are no but let's say 30 and since
you're 10 years old
a canada has troops roaming the streets
and the local government is aligned with
canada
it'd be crazy
it would be crazy so then then when
canada leaves like
i'm i'm not kind of this puppet get out
of here get lost or i'm not i'm not i'm
not going to be in there who are
it's it's i think i think we just don't
have a real appreciation of what it
means to have a farm force be there so
many years yeah massive amount of
resentment you can see it in the numbers
of the taliban increasing like they did
too if those are real numbers it shows
that no one respected the afghan
government as legitimate no one did or
the u.s occupation government either no
they they they feared these feared it
yeah and and so you had peace and you
had stability yes
out of fear but not not out of people
reaching that conclusion for their
country
and and if your local government were to
be
uh in power
because the canadians who are here for
20 years just to make the
that's a funny thought by the way but
again
you know stop a moment and every
intersection is now checkpoint of
canadian soldiers the day they are out
have a nice day bye-bye and you don't
want to be on their side you don't want
to be associated
with anyone in the government in fact
the minute the people in the government
they were propped up by canada
here's the canada's leaving i'm i'm out
i'm not here either you guys ever
watched battlestar galactica yeah oh
yeah you know have you ever seen it it's
good there's a uh i'll just just you
know there's a season where they find a
planet and the cylons you know i'm
talking about the cylons basically
enslave the humans i saw the first
season some of the human silence are
robots they enslave the humans some of
the humans are working with the robots
and so after the humans break free
they're like anybody who worked with
them as a traitor
you know imprison them throw them in the
brig or kick them off or whatever
i like using these pop culture
references because people be like oh
yeah i remember that episode oh yeah so
what do you think is going to happen the
americans are leaving so that's what i'm
saying if we think of everything through
the prism of uh you know trump by the
republicans democrats the
the independent you know the independent
thinking people versus the machine
i think it misses the basic you know try
to put yourself in the shoes of
a 30 year old afghani who since he
is 10 years old he is he remembers
a farm force
sometimes he has uh good memories of
them because they played ball handed out
candies and then
he remembers his father at the dinner
you know uh cursing away
at the uh at these troops and then these
troops come in and sometimes they're
there to help it took away a bad guy and
then the next day the bad guy is your
uncle so you probably think he wasn't
the bad guy it's the military is bad
and then when they leave like it it's
it's it's a complex relationship i think
let's talk about china yeah i got this
meme guys i got this meme um it's
actually just a news article technically
the truth
china's state media mocked the u.s
withdrawal in afghanistan saying the
taliban takeover was quote more smooth
than the presidential transition into
the u.s that's true
i just got to say uh in terms of
roasting and trolling china wow that's
an emmy right there they uh that's a
smack in the face to the us that's a
good troll
it's kind of it's kind of sad though
isn't it they're right i mean american
domestically they're right for domestic
news media it gets worse
in a statement from the global times
which is chinese state media basically
the mouthpiece of the chinese communist
party from what happened in afghanistan
those in taiwan should perceive that
once a war breaks out in the straits the
island's defense will collapse in hours
and the u.s military won't come to help
as a result the dpp will quickly
surrender
china's didn't say if war breaks out
they said when a1 breaks out once i'm
sorry once a war breaks out there you go
once the war breaks out
so i'm i'm asking you again what i asked
earlier who in the u.s
has the appetite who has in which
political party which force which
machines or
you know whether republicans democrats
activists uh
uh media which which uh um
think tanks which institution
in the u.s has patience for
wars to protect other countries
and especially especially when there are
so many people in the u.s again
institutions in the u.s who didn't have
even who didn't have the appetite to
take on china even on trade
or to take an even european trade i mean
you have people here who will tell you
that if
the eu has a 10 percent tariffs
on products coming in from the us to
europe
we shouldn't have the same we shouldn't
you know so so people are you know
nobody wants war no no but it's worse
people aren't even willing to put up a
fight on tariffs to protect jobs and the
economy in the u.s right who's going to
who's going to say yeah i think we
should we need to defend taiwan and i
think china sees that it's not just that
the u.s the
government propped up but the u.s
collapsed i think china is aware of
uh the u.s not having the appetite yeah
it's the apathy of the american people
war weariness
there's a difference between
the war in afghanistan and uh and taiwan
we i think afghanistan's a huge mistake
we it was
it was just stupid iraq was stupid a lot
of things the us does in the middle east
are very very stupid taiwan is an ally
and we have allies in southeast asia and
in the pacific and it's a huge threat if
china starts attacking them and the u.s
would need to defend them however i
don't think anybody you're right has an
appetite for war
but i don't think you need to have an
epidemic for war if you have a president
and administration strong enough to just
set that boundary that can't be crossed
and i certainly think as i stated with
the taliban and what we're seeing now
you look at the economic crisis you look
at the what did joe biden just do he
increased uh uh um food benefit payments
uh snap uh food stamps
25 which says two things one more more
money being given out which is already
bad for the escalating inflation and two
it shows that inflation on food is here
to stay now they've got to increase it
and they're saying it's because they
want to make sure people get more
nutrients okay well then you're just
giving more free money away so people
are going to be less incentivized to
work you you may tell me i mean the
taliban certainly noticed the weakness
of the bina administration but you take
a look at what china knows china's
engaged in cyber warfare they got a
great intelligence they are they are
very powerful and they're looking at
this and they know exactly what they can
and can't do and right now i think this
statement they're putting out they're
not joking they're not say
this is not meant to intimidate uh or
make it or or you know tell the us how
we're coming they're saying now we're
gonna do it
and no one's going to stop us because
americans are i mean
look at the way china crack down on hong
kong and
i don't think anyone you know speaks up
uh or wants to do anything about it
uh
the reason for it i don't know this is
this is how it is maybe it is because of
the us was so so heavily involved
in these two countries over the last two
decades at a steep cost to the country
in terms of
uh um
[Music]
soldiers dying or being wounded
and you have families suffering
and people don't even know to our end to
accomplish what so people just become
tired it's like a game almost yes and i
think and i think um
i think there's also a different level
of what you know different level of
patriotism
today versus many years ago
uh i think this also plays into
into a lot of it i think a generation or
two ago people were more willing
to fight for the country i think today
you have it less what's the reason i
don't know
but i think i think this is a factor so
if people don't have the appetite to
fight for their country i'm not
saying with people you know tweeting for
their country people think that's
considered fighting you know standing up
to trump tweeting for the country resist
uh you know then why would they why
would they want to be involved in taiwan
and china i don't know that's that's why
i wonder we asked this question of a lot
of people you know is is the culture war
a product of america's enemies
sowing divisions online i mean we we
heard all the reports of you know
russian interference and how russia had
been running different sides of the
culture war so
the impact was microscopic first and
foremost but what they would do is
these these uh internet
trolls would create a black lives matter
facebook page and then like an
anti-black lives matter page and then
they would organize protests around each
other so that those conflicts could
happen granted it doesn't seem like they
had a tremendous impact but when i look
at what's happening in the u.s
the
i mean how about this what was it colin
kaepernick i think complained about the
american flag shoe and they banned it
yeah betsy
one of the most psychotic and insane
things i've ever heard one of the one of
the symbols of the founding of this
country when you lose that cohesion you
fall apart and now look at where we are
you look at afghanistan no no social
cohesion no national identity and they
just collapse no cultural identity
except for the taliban of course and
they sweep in like that because they've
got a passion for their cause
now you look what's happening with the
1619 project welkness critical race
applied principles and you have an
entire faction of people who
don't like this country i'll tell you
this
i think it was a was it jimmy fallon
he did uh was it was it fallon he did a
uh census data came out and it shows
that for the first time the white
population has shrunk and the audience
starts busting out clapping and cheering
and then he looks like why are you like
what
i didn't i didn't watch the whole show
but i saw that clip and it was why were
they clapping for that i mean probably
probably 80 of the audience was white no
right
like you think about the
self-destructive nature of these these
white
uh establishment liberal type
personalities but i think a lot of the
conversations um in this in this arena i
think is also people are just bored out
of their mind and they're looking for
for for reason to belong some somewhere
or some place
to accomplish like why not go help a
local soup kitchen and they get involved
and they would say
some stupidity it's like you're not
you're not changing anything and
then they sit there and clap you're
clapping for what it's it's it's strange
but how how about we all agree that
china is a major threat and we can rally
around defending you know the people of
taiwan or standing up for them or having
having a cohesive
message of you know we will defend our
allies instead it's just
i don't know man
ragging on people based on their race or
gender or just self-loathing and hating
themselves
i'm not well i think i think many people
who uh you know supposedly is are self
loathing as based on their racial ethnic
background i think a lot of it is not
real i think they they there's it's just
a genre to get retweets or
to get attention
i mean it's it's not it's not legit i
mean probably 95 percent you know in the
past at least 95 percent people in the
us would live in communities that
reflect their own ethnicity or culture
or marry into
families that fit their culture and
ethnicity so a lot of these
a lot of these posts and and videos and
articles i think it's just people
looking for attention to be uh relevant
they want to get along on the bandwagon
of something
um but but the point is it shows that we
have nothing that unifies us
it's it's it's what unifies us as our
hatred for each other in this country
and so you have
you have the culture war the culture war
left and the culture were right and
there's some overlap and weird it's like
we should draw a map so maybe maybe you
know maybe that's the byproduct of
having peace and prosperity you don't
have the worries and concerns that we do
though we have we have china we have
russia but then but then but then we are
so partisan these days that people uh
would take positions on foreign policy
based on which president can get more
credit or more hits over the head you
know figuratively speaking so it's what
i'm saying is uh going back to the 70s
and the 80s even you know
people were scared from uh the ussr at
the time
people people had
i think the minds of people were busy
with um
with the well-being of the us
but i think we we live uh for a
generation already in a in a situation
where there's a lot of peace and a lot
of prosperity okay fine i mean there's
been 911 and other stuff but relatively
speaking it's not
people don't wake up every day this you
have this big russian monster the big
ussr they tried yeah but but people
don't feel people don't feel it this way
the last 20 30 years so you have a a
whole generation our generation being
raised spoiled brats and we have the
world at our fingertips and then we see
people writing interesting articles and
they get the retweets and the likes and
i get invited on tv and they want in on
it
yeah
it's
it's a shame because so much of this
energy can be used
can be used on bringing people together
on concerns that are legitimate concerns
about um
take the issue take the issue of you
know please please brutality that's very
popular in the liberal field i think at
this this
day and age i think a lot of people will
admit that there are reforms that can be
had in law enforcement but if you make
everything a racial issue when there are
multiple incidents of
police officers who are minority
physically abusing fellow minorities
then obviously the issue of the issues
of challenges on law enforcement is not
exclusively or not only are not
primarily race-based so why are you
making it about race when
i think there needs to be some overall
who gets hired how they're hired the
training i mean
your standard police officer again i'm
not i'm not picking on police officers
as the individual talking about the
training
they can sometimes pull over someone in
the afternoon sitting there with a
family it's it's it's four o'clock in
the afternoon
it's a family man if you will and the
tone is if you just stopped as a a
terror suspect it's like everyone is
dealt with as if they are a suspect of
something something is wrong with the
training yeah something is wrong with
training a police officer that they can
go this crazy this quick against a
person who is otherwise
a civilian and then there's also a lack
of accountability
in law enforcement
um i'm not saying now the wall of blue
silence uh whatever else called it's
just
you know it's
who who is accountable to whom
so and so a lot of these things i think
lead to to challenges in how to police a
community so rather than people coming
together law enforcement and civilians
people from old backgrounds to to pass
laws and rules how to make things better
the whole conversation gets hijacked
about race and once you do that you lose
half the country and that's why let me
just wrap it up with this and that's why
we're debating today in 2021 the same
issues of police brutality that we did
20 30 years ago without much change
i think we're missing
uh uh cohesive suffering as a society
or suffering or worry or concerned such
as you had with russia thirty four years
ago russia
helped a lot like fear and worry is
helpful but real suffering you can is
undeniable like if i'm suffering in the
police officer are both suffering
because we're both looking for food i'm
like okay we're both in a bad place you
have it a little worse because you've
got to go fight guys for a living but at
least we can get we can agree we're both
suffering and we have a shared focus
as a species to get food but now that's
completely in the united states there's
no suffering might i have to induce it
on myself psychedelics make you suffer
correct even even even basic crime rates
however bad things are the last 12
months
if if you want to compare to to the
1990s i mean 20 25 years ago it's
beautiful again god forbid you know any
single person getting attacked or the
i'm not speaking about the individual
victim but again as a society
it's generally more safer to go out on
this people have less worry as they had
20 40 years ago and i think people think
people are just going crazy no i think
you're crazy i think you gotta rephrase
it people have less to worry about but
they're more worried than ever
okay it's because because we all have
our exactly as uh so someone someone
just you know text me i shouldn't use my
phone while i'm on the show you know
it's that bad this is this is uh the
thing about police brutality that i've
brought up several times the reason
there's such a hyper focus on it is
because it plays well for social media
people know that if they post these
videos if they complain about it they'll
get clicked retweets and followers so
they they played into it
it's shock content it's violent content
and it's interesting i'm okay with all
of that in other words i understand the
the drive that people have
uh you know to get uh well what i'm
saying is the only thing they'll see is
that they don't mean anything reality oh
okay in other words they don't want to
see a fix or solution no no no no no you
got a 10 year old kid he goes on
facebook for the first time and 50
adults are sharing police brutality for
for retweets for shares that kid will
see nothing but police brutality 10
years later say they're born in 2010 or
let's say they're born in 2000 they're
10 years old in 2010 they get on twitter
or whatever they're not supposed they're
too young to do anyway they see endless
streams of police brutality for a decade
then they're 20 going why won't anyone
do anything about this and it's like bro
turn off the phone and go outside it's
not happening it happens it's bad when
it does it's a valid point in other
words the the the
the reality becomes misconstrued it
becomes it becomes uh
all messed up things are not sometimes
as bad as people think as it is as you
said
um there's you know the video the videos
of a police officer you know playing
basketball with a local uh with a couple
of kids is not going to get so much
attention
as a police officer doing something bad
right and but again okay so i was going
to say that there's there's similar
criticism to go to
uh in today's sense with
antifa violence and blm rights and stuff
footage that gets recycled over and over
and over again because it plays well but
i would say that tendency is more the
exception and not the rule because the
media mostly ignores it and it doesn't
play well it doesn't play but tim you
know there's this old joke you have i
don't know how many flights in the air
that and at any given time seven
thousand whatever
all those flights landing you're not
gonna have a reporter well look there's
another plane landing right another one
you have one plane even the three people
on it you know crashing down on the
freeway right exactly it's gonna become
national news that's how humans are
right so so the issue is someone could
share a video of antifa and it'll play
well with some people who are like this
is bad but police brutality makes
everyone even conservatives get angry so
if you look at like george floyd for
instance you know you get people like
ben shapiro and sean hannity coming up
like weird we are we are upset by this
correct so i i'm not
i don't have a problem please brutality
being a discussion because i think there
are reforms to be had what i'm saying is
that the
the
the solution of it i think a couple uh
six weeks ago there were a couple of
police officers who beat up a child a
teenager or what have you in a retail
store
um
i think
two of the officers at a minimum were
minority officers and the victim was
awesome it wasn't even a story
so that's the
what i'm trying to tell what i'm trying
to say is this
i understand the the the shock value you
know why it becomes news but i'm i'm
also saying that a lot of times people
don't want to have real solutions of
course they want to fit into into a
certain narrative a certain agenda for
whatever reason
and therefore things don't get corrected
such as so many issues on police
brutality because i think some of the
core causes are not addressed who gets
hired sometimes crazies get hired into
law enforcement
complete clowns get hired and you don't
have a good screening process and then
the training sometimes is is is insane
and then sometimes a lack of oversight
so if if you don't address any of these
core issues and you and you only focus
let's say on race then so many of these
incidents will not get fixed so what
going back to what i said a minute ago
and as you said it correctly
there isn't a shared suffering a shared
worry
and
so people have extra time in their mind
how how can i how can i become busy
and then you have a cause have a cause
and then you have social media and you
see you know certain things play well
you want to get along on it and you can
make a lot of money spreading negative
information you get very famous very
quickly on the internet because that
stuff spreads like wildfire negative
information or information that's very
popular at the time it's like if you
notice in institutional media
uh you know i have it sometimes in in
the private practice
um when i when clients retain me and i
need to work with them on media outreach
it's like
if you want to pitch a story to a
reporter if if no other journalist
picked it up that that journal is going
to say no i i don't know why why will i
do it and sometimes if one person has it
everyone has it so people like to people
like to jump on imperative abandoning
it's an impossible problem to solve you
know mentioning the negative money cycle
the next i'm sorry the negative news
cycle and the money made because i mean
what are we doing
we're we're going on a show we're saying
oh look at what's happened here and
that's bad and this is bad and we're
it's almost kind of uh uh
it's it's kind of a it's a recursive
loop of us being like people sharing
negative information on the internet is
is bad it's like literally doing that in
this in the space of doing it now here's
the point i'm making
what would happen if we decided to stop
talking about the things we thought were
were bad and and we stopped talking
about the news and these negative things
then you would have more and more bad
things happen because people wouldn't be
paying attention and and would be
allowed to fester and grow
so i think if you go to any person even
a black lives matter activist who's
saying please brutality 24 7.
well they're going to be like i'm not
doing anything wrong i'm not doing this
because i want to be rich i'm doing it
because place brutality is a problem and
then when you're like yeah but when you
have a hundred thousand people posting
police brutality over and over and over
and kids don't see anything else it's
making them lose their minds
i don't know how you solve for that
problem people are allowed to be
passionate and fight for what they
believe in i think there's a balance of
um you too much talking about problems
creates more problems too not enough
talking about problems creates more
problems because they're not being
addressed so you want to address them
and then solve them and then not address
them anymore
uh unless they're still a problem and
the solution didn't work and then you've
got to readdress them and address a new
solution right the equation problem
without a solution is basically like the
bigger but the bigger problem is again
let's talk about a problem is that
people sometimes don't want a solution
outside of a set narrative right i think
that's more destructive than people
talking about problems i love that then
we can debate the solution as opposed to
debating we know what the problem is a
lot of times but but the people don't
want to have
uh
people don't want to debate the solution
i have a friend a very very liberal
friend and i told him that police
brutality has many factors not related
not police brutality has many factors
not related
to to
racism
he was ready to to bite my head off but
then i explained
you know some of the thinking as i did a
couple of minutes ago he was willing to
to listen so i don't think the issue is
you know we can talk about problems all
day china taiwan
inflation the border afghanistan but
the i think where people get stuck is
having constructive conversations about
solutions it's also good to debate
problems because sometimes you'll see a
problem in a different way than someone
else i think a lot of critical race
especially that some like robin d'angelo
i'd like to have her on the show and
talk to her because i think she sees the
problem differently than i do and if we
can somehow redefine the problem this is
a place that we can both understand then
we can start redefining a solution
that might right but like he said some
people don't want solutions well and i
don't think she does she does not she
doesn't she does everything is racist no
matter what she makes money you change
like what we want can change so she
maybe she will one day start to watch
solutions that's and that's yeah that
does give us all our money this brings
me yeah this brings me this brings me to
another point um
that many people do not want to fix a
certain problem they do not want to have
a solution it's like
people think uh you know if only you're
going to show people numbers about
coronavirus and this age and that age
then people will change their opinion
about
vaccine passports they don't care they
want everyone to have a vaccine passport
they don't want to hear different
information and if you give them
information from the cdc oh it's this
you know they give you the buzzwords of
you spreading this information some
people are sold or hooked on a certain
narrative and they don't care about
fixing it let me i'll give you an
example so during the the mediterranean
migrant crisis it was the migrant crisis
because even the u.n came out and said
uh oh actually let me start over
so uh we had this crisis i'm sure many
of you are familiar with where you had a
lot of people from afghanistan and syria
and iraq and other middle eastern
countries
fleeing through
the eastern mediterranean uh
from like syria into say you know into
europe and things like that
and that was the result of a lot of the
conflict in the middle east but it
quickly turned into a north african um
migrant crisis
where the u.n said these people are
economic migrants not refugees now i i
made that distinction when i reported on
it at the start of the refugee chrysler
i'm like refugees are fleeing from the
east then later on it was like the new
the latest information says they're
actually coming from north africa and
they're coming you know into libya and
then they're trying to come into europe
these are not refugees for the most part
they're economic migrants looking for
work i had a friend who was posting all
his activist stuff and i was talking to
her someone i've known for a really long
time and when i said hey here's the
latest report from the un
these you know clearly states these are
economic migrants so we can certainly
try and defend their lives we don't want
them to drown or anything but i think
that distinction is important when we're
trying to address what these people are
looking for
block
she's she literally just blocked me she
did not want to hear the truth about
what the u.n was saying about this
crisis so a friend of mine blocked me
that's how entrenched in ideologies
people are they don't want a solution
they don't want to know what's going on
they have this tribal desire to say i'm
on the right side of history this is
what my my community says and nothing
else matters and so what happens when
you have an ideology like that that's
basically a religion you'll never stop
even if you win
not with text you can't conf convince
those people with texts
you got to talk to them and you got to
hit them when they're not expecting it
with your voice real subtle and like in
your tone that's very like cordial and
understanding and calm and committing
and then all of a sudden before they
realize that they believe what you said
it's i i i but i think um
i think the person who blocked tim is
the person was probably worked up about
a certain cause and tim was just there
you know taking it away now what right
which takes us back to what we discussed
the start of discussing 10 minutes ago
people lose a sense of belonging or
accomplishing waking up in the morning
fine you work you go to school or
whatever you have family and then what
people people like action in terms of
activity accomplishing it used to worry
about about something didn't have
anything it used to be religion yeah it
used to be that making sure you were
doing right by whatever your religious
doctrine said uh for a lot of people in
america was doing right by god and
living a a you know the right kind of
life but we can make a point
people say that they're going to be in
the right side of history
why do we need to wait for history it's
because the prism of history is usually
opposite of what has been believed to be
the right thing at the time so you can't
be
thinking you're right now and going to
be right through the prism of history
and also the point yeah i think a lot
about people great people that are alive
today that are receiving a lot of
suffering or immediate negativity is
like dude you're gonna be can retrobated
in the future man can we can we just
think about what that means the right
side of history they're not saying
they're correct they're saying
in time we will crush you that's what
they're saying okay that's that's a more
cynical way of putting it than maybe but
history is written by the vectors look
correct correct but there's also but the
real meaning of history will judge this
way that way is that a lot of times
things which seemed to be popular and
accepted at the time
turned out through the prism of history
to be seen as crazy and insane and
abusive so if you are now if your
political or policy position now is
popular it's what it's 95 percent of
media output it's it's cool and hip
there's a big chance that history is
going to look at it differently which is
why we need to wait for history although
as he said the victor writes he wanted
so yeah i'll tell you what's funny is
when you hear that during the civil
rights era
what were uh uh
proponents of segregation saying so it's
a private business freedom to associate
they can exclude anybody you want from
their private business and we said
nah you can't do that anymore which i
think is the right decision now you look
at where we're at with big tech
censorship of certain political opinions
and it's the establishment democrat
liberal types saying but they're a
private business they can do what they
want just absolutely bending the need to
massive multinational corporations and
literally being on the side of private
businesses like yeah but i don't i don't
i don't think i don't think the the
standard democrat that favors um the
censorship does so to bend the knee to a
big corporation they're doing it because
you know list me five um
non-conservatives that have been
suspended by twitter
real people except for the there's
actually there's a lot no the big guys
not
the big names off of tv and so forth
it's very limited on the republican side
or not even republican just the right
leaning side of several sides every
other day another person goes goes
missing there are a lot of anti-war left
and anti-capitalists left who have been
banned but big names big names i i would
say household names like uh it's very
difficult to find you you have the who
who's the person who made that ahead
from trump what's her name oh kathy
cathy griffin yeah yeah
there is not one conservative not one
person in in the right side of
parliament at the right as the
conservative with the right-wing side
that can do anything that she has done
and still be alive on twitter that was
pretty brutal and not well she got that
not just oh she's on twitter yeah
and the same thing
with keith olbermann oh yeah i don't
know the the the the he's abusive
i i like to tell people like troll or
mute me you know i like to kid around to
people if some you know if someone is
out there on twitter and takes it you
know personal okay you know i'll stop he
he go he goes off derails every other
tweet in abusive language on a violation
of the twitter rules and he's still
there point being i don't think
democrats are on the side of the big
corporations they're just happy that the
big corporations of course tend to be
staff apparently mostly by people who
are aligned but but look at it this way
when they're happy that
twitter for instance is going to remove
their political opponents they're laying
down their sword they're saying we're
not going to go after them because we
we're we're benefiting from this so it's
it's like you know application of
responsibility but bending the knee it's
the corporation's breaking social norms
it's destroying our culture and our
country and they're going to them saying
but i get what i want so carry on good
sir exactly and and and i think um we
have seen a lot of hate from
democrats from washington against
facebook over the last five years
because facebook did one thing
they treated trump in 2016 as a client
and they worked with them and they were
not going to forgive facebook for
treating trump as a client because they
treat banter pair like a client correct
and they kept on pushing and pushing and
pushing and you know to keep uh facebook
kept on getting much more heat from
washington than than the twitter and i
think it's just payback for how they
were and not only this i think people
think that um
trump won he had these narrow wins by
utilizing
facebook as an as an instrument and
people don't want to forget forgive
facebook this is it is a first amendment
issue we were talking about earlier
about defining the problems and agreeing
on the problems what they mean and what
they are and solutions being able to
talk and define those things if we can't
do that on social media or in a public
place then our first amendment is being
violated and we're not going to be able
to solve any of our problems but but
many people don't care i i think we all
have this cute assumption that everyone
who lives in the us or was born in the
u.s
favors individualism private property
rights gun rights freedom of speech
religious freedom why
why do we have the assumption that every
person who you meet on the street is
just
believes in standard you know core
american values that i just listed and
maybe they have a different perspective
on the minimum wage if it should be uh
10 or 15 no you have a lot of people who
who subscribe to to a fascist
perspective or to a
a stalinist perspective
and not because they're bad people
because they they have generally a
different world view
than you may have them i may have so we
have this assumption that everyone is
out there just
thinking and believing and wanting the
freedom of speech freedom of religion
gun rights gun rights and and
and individualism private property is
that the freedom to to send your child
to school and to get an education and to
work and we'll debate you know if we
need to have a lockdown for a week or no
many people do not want that they
absolutely do not care they do not share
the same values as you do on these basic
uh american principles that were popular
a generation or two ago so then you tell
well you know you can't debate it okay
they don't care
they don't care let me i'll just stress
this too and it's the establishment
democrats for the most part my favorite
example is that when you ask an
independent voter or republican how the
economy is doing they'll say fairly bad
democrats say fairly good but if you
actually look at the data it's like
really bad yeah but this but this i
think uh this can be influenced by uh
what you said is you know it's become a
popular buzzword the tribalism what i'm
they're adhering to the authority the
media the media and the system and the
political establishment say it's true so
it's true the critical thinkers who are
like show me the evidence this is uh
i think this is why you get you get the
culture war break apart uh with left and
right as it is establishment democrat
types will just say something today and
then contradict themselves tomorrow
they'll scream and cry about a
conservative doing something and then do
it themselves because they don't care
about principle they care about
following the authority correct uh you
know the um
i i wrote this on twitter a couple of
times
um one of the people who attended the
obama birthday party released videos and
she apologized for releasing the video
erica badu right yeah so i i asked i
asked on twitter why do you need to
apologize i think other people should
release videos too like
if you think that you have done
something which is okay release the
video
but they wanna hide it they wanna they
wanna deny that they attended this event
why
probably because there are people there
who favor lockdown so favor vaccine
passports has nothing to do with
not because they're concerned about
coronavirus they have a certain world
view of how societies need to be run
and it doesn't mean that they personally
fear coronavirus if yes they wouldn't go
to the event so they're
being a fan of let's say the vaccine
passport to many of those people is not
out of fear of coronavirus many people
are worked up to many people it's just
they think that this is how society
should run it should be a stricter
regime about
vaccines so those people have no problem
going to an event next day without a
mask or something it's because
they don't have a problem with it rules
for the event yeah correct there's a
simple question that i think all of you
can uh benefit from ian
yes tim do you think vaccines are good
things well
i mean a vaccine done right yes is a
good thing do you think that people
should have the choice to make medical
decisions for themselves
often there are situations where
emergencies may require that people
submit to authority for the greater good
which is terrifying to say are you
saying yes or no should people have the
right to choose medical decisions about
what they do with their body
sometimes so the answer is no you think
it's it's
rights are given you know
so people should you're saying people
should not have the choice i think that
in a free society um yeah but if
you know you're you're under martial
lockdown and like uh cholera breaks out
and you you're able to vaccinate all the
the people right it's simple you kind of
got to do it without asking absolutely
it's really simple yeah you're an
authoritarian and sometimes there's no
sometimes there's value to staging
authority yeah uh
libertarians typically don't take
authoritarian positions what are you
gonna do if you have 7000 people and
they're all have a vicious virus that's
mutating and
making them bleed from their eyes and
you have the vaccine but what are you
going to go ask everyone for their
permission
yes that's not how it works dude that's
not how smallpox worked that's that's
sometimes there's an emergency where
right so you accept authoritarianism
sometimes but the problem i have is i
think people are overblowing covet can i
can i hold on hold on like you either
the the challenge with you ian as you
can't just you're trying to get a black
and white answer man that's just not the
way people should have a right to choose
their own medical decisions and they
should go talk to doctors about what
makes sense what about the smallpox
vaccine
i still think people have a right to
choose for themselves they didn't though
that was like forced on people okay the
issue now is that with the mandates the
argument is whether or not people have a
choice you have establishment uh even
some you know neocon types who are
saying people should not have a choice
at all and they're coming out on media
and saying do everything possible to
harm them until they capitulate i think
that's authoritative should be is cova
dangerous enough that it warrants
giving people no choice that's your
private medical decision with your
doctor that's my
overarching of the structure of society
that's how i think we should look at
diseases
it's really simple it is you're an
authoritarian i mean not but not
generally but i understand the value of
authority from time to time people who
fall in libertarian spectrum typically
say things like
okay so a libertarian approach to this
would be like my opinion and and one i
genuinely thought you'd have is vaccines
are fantastic
amazing technology in fact i'm looking
over the mrna stuff it sounds really
really fascinating and amazing and i
can't tell someone to do what the
what they should do with their body
because i believe that we have to
respect the individual's right to choose
so what we can do is private businesses
if they say they want to mandate masks
i'm like dude i'm not going to you know
make an issue of a mom and pop shop
saying you can't come in my store within
reason because as we already mentioned
with civil rights i think there are
limits so i certainly respect
the power of authority in certain
instances which is why i said typically
when i say i'm left libertarian i'm not
big a libertarian i say i'm usually
liberal because i actually think some
things i agree with you in that sense
yeah but tim i i think you're setting it
up it's like asking someone this food
the good thing or not tell me is food
good or not um yeah it is good oh so you
favor obesity no i'm not out of favor of
bdc oh you want people to die from
hunger i think so much of the discussion
again i'm glad how you you framed the
question because i think people need to
think
what they believe whether it's ian or
your audience or myself and you but a
lot of times the the question as i just
said it is do you favor food or not if
you you know if you favor food but
so so the same thing is is is the
concept of vaccines good amazing have
you seen how the world has changed uh
over the years of course but then
therefore because it's good like you
know do you believe in science you don't
believe in science well if you don't
believe in science why do you fly
airplane well just because i believe in
science doesn't mean every clown that
puts together a couple of wires i'm
going to sit onto it and and and and
take off
right so in this particular instance you
know i'm not saying in the greater of of
everything related to ian's character
and the point i'm trying to get to is
when i mention civil rights i say i
think it's good that there were mandates
and that there was respect for certain
instances of authority the issue is that
you've got people who are looking at the
media and saying i want to see the
information i want to see the data and
make that choice for myself and how that
plays into the greater society and the
decisions decisions we make and then you
have people saying shut up and do as
you're told because
no because as i said before they are
authoritarian or they are they are
stalinists they they are fascists they
are not inter they don't think or
believe that people should have a
certain level of liberty and choice
and and therefore they push against it
you know a point that i that i uh try to
make often is um you know now there it's
an emergency we need to have lockdowns
this and that
what i try to argue is
the the the authoritarian the despot do
you think he goes out there announcing
hi everyone i'm a despot i want to take
away your rights stay home tonight it
doesn't work this way it's always
packaged that there that it's an
emergency or it's for good of country uh
uh so so i'm not saying that someone who
favors a lockdown due to coronavirus is
the same as a murderous despot from 50
years ago i'm saying that being in an
emergency
isn't the reason to suspend rights
because we need the rights because it's
an emergency when it's an emergency when
you want to challenge that's exactly
when we need it i want to make sure i
make i
act clarify the point i'm trying to make
there are people who have told me that
i'm a fascist because i said i think
taxes are fine you know i've had
libertarians be like taxation is theft
and i'm like i think not paying taxes
theft because from my perspective you
know we we enter into the society with
16 years of free life where you get
roads you get water you get all of the
regulations you get police fire
department ems
and you pay no taxes because you're not
working your parents are and then when
you get a job they say after your free
16 years you can now start paying into
the system i'm being somewhat facetious
and just making an argument but people
have said that's you know authoritarian
or [ __ ] to force me to pay for you and
all that stuff and i'm like then stop
coming to my town and driving in my
roads wherever the point i'm making is
it's it's less about the principles of
being being free letting people do
whatever they want which libertarians
certainly are like big libertarians are
basically like do your thing leave me
alone i'll do my thing i'll leave you
alone
it's it's it's personal moral ethics i
suppose when an individual says i don't
think she should be able to segregate on
the basis of race it's not so much about
the principle of freedom it's about
what weighs more in your mind uh morally
i think
rejecting someone from a business who
lives in the community and pays taxes is
wrong if you're doing it for arbitrary
reasons other people think i'm imposing
you know authority over them so that
that's the challenge the challenge so
real quick the point i'm making is ian
if i say do you believe this people will
say you're an authoritarian because you
believe we should have these measures
even if on most things you're like
people should be free to do what they
want i when i look at vaccines i'm
thinking about my i got six when i was a
baby um hepatitis b i think i didn't ask
for it authoritarian authoritarianism
reigns supreme i was just injected as a
baby um and probably for the greater
good the mmr we don't know
mmr measles mumps and rubella would kill
kill people i wasn't killed by it i was
vaccinated against my will i didn't even
have willpower at that point in my life
so
in those cases yeah man i guess i i
support that from what i know parental
authority too but i mean this is like
military government
this is your we got to keep parents
doctors and the doctor giving them
advice you're not going to make it seem
like you know this is not i think it's
more about like the science like the
science it's so vague but like the
reality you can't make if you're going
to be a military commander and decide
life and death for your troops and and
the enemy's troops you need to know you
need to be do you need to do it right
but uh but
again a lot of people don't care for
example
uh i want to give an interesting data
point um
in new york city the mayor bill de
blasio announced essentially vaccine
passports to go to gyms and terrestrons
but if you're vaccinated
against coronavirus you'll be able to go
into a restaurant if not you won't be
able to
i have two questions
one question based on two data points
according to newsday which is a long
island newspaper they asked the city and
the city said that in the first six and
a half months of this year
only 1.1 percent of coronavirus cases
were re-infections that's not my data
point it's not pulled out of a hat again
news they reported it
in the name of the new york city health
department saying that only 1.1
reinfections in new york city 1 1.1
coronavirus cases in new york city the
first
six and a half months of yearworry
infections which would probably tell you
that as of now i don't know for how long
as of now
natural immunity from coronavirus is
holding up
quite high again as of now based on the
numbers from new york city from the
infections
on the flip side
we see israel which vaccinated its
population before most other countries
is already pushing a third shot
there they have fizer ready pushing a
third shot for people are 50 or above
that is because over time
the vaccine
efficiency starts going down how long
how strong i know but it starts going
down more than half people last week in
israel in hospitals for coronavirus
serious cases where people who are fully
vaccinated so i have a two data points
one showing based on the news day story
out of new york city data
that natural unity is holding up quite
strong for quite a while at the same
time
the vaccine while it helps it's the it's
it's starting to wane
so why do you have a passport in new
york city
based on vaccination and not based on
immunity if a person can show that they
still have a certain level of antibodies
they say negative tests what is it
negative tests allow you entry as well
um
i think that's only in certain
institutions but i don't think i'm not
i'm not sure but let's say in israel
where they have the the the
vaccine passport
they do count if you were
uh
infected in the past and still have a
certain level of antibodies so there's
in other words i'm more worked out by
the fact that uh you have mark levin he
is the i think the chairman of the
new york city
council health commission committee in
the city council and owen personally i'm
more worked up about him not giving any
legitimacy to people who have been
affected
while he's all in for the vaccine
passport even as we see that the
efficiency starts falling over time it
helps it brought down the numbers but it
starts falling over time so why is this
the only path again
you shouldn't have a pass at all but if
you're going to have a pass why are you
not it's playing even-handed why are you
playing games they're they're they're
gaining power and authority they're lazy
it's power and authority or it's just
lazy it's like too complex you know yeah
it's like what ethan klein said you know
on h3h3 podcast just go just look at
this
if you noticed before i want to get to a
point another point if you notice before
when i said that
natural immunity from coronavirus is
holding up pretty high based on the
newsday story based from new york city
date of the first six and a half months
of the year why am i saying it like in
one sentence it's because if i don't
whoa yoshi's just making up stop you say
your stuff you say
is people don't people don't even want
to have a conversation they'll shut you
down for misinformation even if i'm
giving you data from the new york city
health department as written by newsday
when the democrats say science they're
actually saying consensus exactly
scientists smart yeah because the
scientists who
who oppose these ideas are getting
banned and shut down people like dr
brett weinstein for instance who is an
evolutionary biologist who certainly
knows a bit about the area i'm not a
panel he's a virologist or anything but
they'll just say he's wrong shut him up
science science said this well i know
the other science guy said something too
but i'll always end with this
a lot of people want to believe
what they think makes the most sense for
them based on their world view and then
that doesn't always mean that you're
going to be right and i take a look at
the current system which i'm not a big
fan of the government i don't trust them
all the time but i certainly don't think
they want people to die like look
there's probably evil people somewhere
and sometimes and they do bad things but
i think for the most part
we'll we'll wrap this up and go to super
chats i really do think if you you find
a good doctor someone who pays attention
to the news and is well read in their
field they're going to give you great
advice and become a doctor
now
but tim i don't think the baseline is i
don't think the baseline is that people
want you to die or not i have a problem
again not as a problem but i perplexed
by someone who is he's
a normal person a normal person level
probably have a cell number
why would he dismiss
uh the fact that
the efficiency of the vaccine is
dropping over time as you see a third
shot is being pushed
so why why are you dismissing this why
is this missing why are you dismissing
the there was one study i think came out
we had on timecast.com showing that
astrazeneca and pfizer uh i think it was
pfizer have actually maintained their
efficiency according to a study on
people in the us
so the issue is you'll read some stories
and then you'll say how come they're
just missing this and then i'll read a
story but i have an answer but i have an
answer because because pfizer was pushed
in israel
earlier than probably any other country
or one of the first few so israel is
seeing
the outcome of pfizer
ahead of other countries which is fisa
works the vaccine the double shots work
and therefore the numbers came down and
even florida everyone was busy the last
few weeks of florida florida florida's
death rate this year in the summer death
numbers from coronavirus were much lower
than same time last year so the debate
is not if it works the question is for
how long it works and how effective it
is and why you're dismissing people who
for now again may change and i think it
will be worrisome if it becomes more
widespread that as of now based on new
york city data only 1.1 percent cases
the first half of the year a little bit
more than were the infections why are
you dismissing that we're of those
people were how many of them were
vaccinated
of of the 1.1 yeah of the people that
received covet only 1.1 percent were
reinfected yeah do you know how many of
them i don't know
no the the the reporter mentions that he
asked the city for it and they didn't
answer but the city has a criteria if
someone was someone who had coronavirus
90 days or more before the current
infection that would be counted as a
reinfection and for six and a half
months in new york city it's not a small
place six and a half months city data as
reported by news they're less than two
weeks ago only one point one percent
were the infections which is is an
amazing number so if you if if
cdc says that people with with the
vaccine can have corona virus and can
carry it so how does the past help you
you're giving a pass to someone who can
spread corona it's over the rails and
again i'm not bothered so much by the
insanity of the policies which take away
the freedoms of the fact that people do
not wanna
they're not serious about having a
conversation they don't care they just
hung up on something and finished all
right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
send in the super chats go to
timcats.com become a member we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
around 11 or so pm that's when it goes
up but let's read some of these super
chats we got
flimsy fox says we as a nation have a
history of not doing what we say we're
going to do internationally the issue
with the taliban in afghanistan is of
our own making baiden backed out but
trump should have put the date before
the next term
yeah
let's see buka says hey tim i'm a member
of your website recently i've been
getting this message saying my account
is inactive what's happening
um send an email to members at
timcast.com it could be that your
card doesn't work um isn't it it's
really amazing that that's customer
service right there isn't it you get to
message the show and i tell you right to
you uh if like if if your card didn't go
through properly then you'll get an
active message so you can remember you
can email members at timcast.com and
then someone will get you sorted
taylor norheim says this has happened uh
happened before and it will happen again
all right mike g says tim ian was spot
on about defranco last week i used to
work for him about six years ago and he
was one of the worst bosses i've ever
had so arrogant really what did i say
and said here uh you were saying
something uh like about him being
in the early days of youtube i would
make internet internet videos and we
would go on stickum.com and talk and
phil would come into my chat rooms and
we'd hang out and then i met him at a
7-7 up at youtube live up in san
francisco i always really liked him like
i still like he's really smart really
fearless but i don't know about his
politics i haven't talked to him like a
decade
yeah i've met him a couple times and the
thing we did with talking about phil
defranco is that all of a sudden now
he's posting with his really mean
like it's just i don't know what the
right word is for it it's like hate
filled like yeah just not solution
oriented not calm not rational
just
telling people fu and he's been on the
wrong side of a decent amount of news
stories like covington kids is a really
good example and i'm just like what
happened to us you know like how we've
become this like
maybe i shouldn't say us maybe i should
say what happened to him i don't know no
no it's good take take responsibility
it's a lot of this texting i think i
agree i think social media is having us
all insane yeah but but look i'll i'll
address that too when i when i said
we're sitting here talking about
negative news like i'm going to be fair
we started the vlog specifically to make
fun stuff to counteract that it's on the
website so you're not just going to be
inundated with all this negativity all
the time sometimes you're going to see
us you know playing with chickens and we
had baby chicks hatch and we're gonna be
filming that stuff and playing d and d
we're doing we're doing a tales of
intrigue like paranormal mystery show
we're trying to create a balance of the
information people get so they're not
inundated by this but so many people
have just become vile nasty people i
think people are violent nasty
by nature it's just we see it more
because information travels quicker
these days
and infamy is a little bit like popular
social media you know going crazy and
dropping a bomb so to speak figuratively
speaking i think people like amounts of
money being infamous and or being famous
these days
kyle miller says when i said that kabul
is going to be the saigon of our
generation on friday i did not expect it
to happen over the weekend wasn't that
wild that was uh uh you kyle you nailed
it kyle miller with the prediction but i
think i think a lot of people were
seeing the la the you know the the
seeing the lines being drawn you know
they knew what was coming
and here we
are it's a bummer man
michael mccord said did i just see
adrian curry in the live chat lol yes
you did adrian how's it going what's up
we gotta come back on the show some time
yeah you love to travel
david aloha says why would you ever
conclude djt would bomb when trump has
never wanted to sacrifice lives if it
was an accidental casualty uh it was an
accidental casualty when he took out uh
solomani
um
with trump i'm not yes he he called off
that airstrike on iran said he didn't
want the the amount of lives that would
be lost would be bad
when the taliban is overrunning towns
and there's active combat
do you think that trump wouldn't be
alike we need an airstrike on enemy
combatants storming the city and
threatening to kill or trump wouldn't
want to bend gaza especially yeah
especially if they are between two uh
two cities they're in like some desert
or something small come out as bush
would say
i think trump absolutely uh trump uh one
of the first things he did as president
was he ordered a commando raid in yemen
which resulted in the death of an
eight-year-old american girl
you we can pretend like you know trump
was the hero's gonna save all these
lives but he did a lot of things that
many other presidents did
i just preferred the fact that he was
like i'm getting out of afghanistan and
then started working on ending you know
ending the stuff getting our troops out
of syria
i don't think any of them are perfect i
don't think trump is perfect and i think
the problem with trump and with even
some of obama's early orders is that
they've got this permanent government
people who are appointed to bureaucratic
positions and then you get a president
who sits down and says now i want to do
x and they go
read this then the president reads it
and says what should we do and they say
trust me we'll do this and the president
says you got it and signs off on it yeah
trump was probably going
at first okay i understand okay and then
finally start getting angry no no no
we're not going to do this no i'm done
and they started lying to him then they
started lying to the american people
trump wanted to make moves and they
wouldn't let him the other president's
body probably just says sure whatever
you know you guys know better than i do
i don't want any trouble then you end up
with a president like obama killing a
bunch of americans which she did by the
way
all right
broskadoodle says i disagree with how
trump would have handled it only because
we didn't let the original deal play out
what he would do in this exact is in
this exact situation is irrelevant
because you're playing in the
hypothetical i actually completely agree
with that and that's that's the
challenge i mentioned earlier we have no
frame of reference trump isn't presiding
over this and we can only make
assumptions based on what we think he
would do so it's really based on what
based on what he said or did in in other
instances and maybe maybe would have
been different we don't know and that's
that's why well and if this is the way
we we discuss things then have
have political debates can you can be
shut down because we don't know the
person's not there and you don't even
have a point of reference i think we
have to some extent no i think it's it's
apparent it's fair to point out that
based on what trump did we can make
assumptions about what we think he would
do correct but we can't have an argument
with ourselves in our minds but our
president is not in office yeah it's
it's not about uh being uh certain that
he would do it but it's you know to
entertain it as a possibility if not a
probability the point is worth getting
emotional about you you've got all these
democrats saying it's trump's fault and
i'm like trump's not the president all
right no
democrats saying it's trump's fault then
biden goes out and says it's my credit
so
but he did say i inherited this from
trump and i had to make a hard decision
but the buck stops with me and i'm like
all right fine i'll take it you know
sean debbie says trump was adamant about
not leaving arms and equipment as a
free-for-all that is true and there was
a statement from mike pompeo where he
said that uh i think i think it was
trump or i can't remember who someone
said to the taliban
that the full force of america will rain
down on them if they violate the deal or
or things like that
and i think with trump in office the
taliban were like all right all right
we're gonna get something out of this
and this dude's gonna okay we don't
wanna we don't want to mess with this
guy's crazy okay with joe biden they're
like he's sleeping run
and that's what you get man
jason straight says cowardly of biden to
address the nation at 4pm a busy time of
day when no one is available to watch in
any case anything he says rings hollow
as he's made it clear many times he's
not uh that he's not my president
yeah a lot of people said the same thing
about donald trump um the issue is i i
can understand that joe biden doesn't
represent uh in my opinion
everyone in this country and that's like
uh
i got to slow down i'll give you the
example when covert restrictions were
being lifted in texas and florida biden
came out and said we might have to have
more lockdowns and things like that as
if texas and florida did not exist at
all as if these red states didn't exist
and so i think he's been doing a very
very bad job in that regard and i think
jason is correct
a lot of people pointed out as a 3 45
you know scheduled press conference when
people are at work
are you serious
8 p.m
you know later in the evening when
people have a chance to watch it
yeah but in the i think uh
2021 people would just take out their
phone oh yeah watch that online or
something on demand yeah basically
sorta i can't read your last name says
why would an islamic people who have
been taught their entire lives that
westerners are bad according to the
quran embrace western democracy american
politicians media and military officers
have no respect or insight into other
cultures
i don't know a lot about islam i think
that one of the tenets of islam is if
you're backed into a corner fight with
everything you have and they feel like
they've been pushed into a corner
economically as the military-industrial
complexes
spread throughout the region this is
this is important all right go ahead no
no i i think i think uh it's possible
that the religious perspective plays a
role to some people to some actors but i
think we can't dismiss the
the human flow of things as the
example that i gave earlier about canada
imagine growing up 20 years of having
canadian troops making checkpoints at
every corner and one day they play ball
with you and the next day uh
they arrest your uncle because he's
supposedly a bad guy your uncle was in
prison for two years i think
i think this this
excuse me i think this puts um
the u.s an impossible position when they
move into an area and then what
all right jason diaz says who played
civilization not to conquer anyone yo
cultural victories man dude science
launch that spaceship man i keep
thinking about this if we had conquered
in civilization have you ever played civ
it's a computer game it's a great game
it's world conquest you can do it by
culture you can do it by science you can
do it you build a civilization uh
religion you can do it by conquest you
don't have to conquer the world through
conquest
the most the culture
i played was pac-man or pac-man
if you were to game boys if you were to
conquer a desert mountain country like
afghanistan and then there are all these
cities you'd have to spend so much money
building libraries
uh sewers
uh
marketplaces
universities i mean you'd spend so much
money bankrupt yourself like seven times
so i see how it's just an impossible win
using the civilization metaphor well
it's like nusav you go to an area that's
like a desert region there's no
resources you just just raise it to the
ground and leave no you're cultural
victory you i don't like conquest i like
cultural victory it's where it's
basically in the game you export your
culture your movies your your music and
then other other countries are adopting
your behaviors
and then your borders expand and press
on theirs and then people are like
that's way cooler than this and then
they rebel or abandon anyway we gotta we
got an actual important super chat here
uh no no offense jason i just mean it
was a funny hokey one but this one is
like uh actually interesting john hutto
says the 200k number for taliban
fighters comes from a january 2021 west
point counter-terror center volume 14
issue one report quoting a bbc report in
2018 from dr dawood azami and a tweet i
tagged lids on very interesting that the
initial source goes back to 2018 which
would suggest that much of this growth
happened under obama and biden and by
changing the source it now makes it
appear as though the latest development
happened under donald trump i love how
media's played isn't it
shepherd in studios says cassandra's
comment about biden's speech was
incredibly short-sighted it was sculpted
to achieve exactly the results she gave
perhaps
but i think there's a rhetorical victory
in the president coming out and
repeating the words of what many
anti-war activists have said for a long
time about the wasted time and energy
and money in afghanistan and it's
vindication it's it's getting them to
admit that the anti-war crowd was right
the whole time and they believed the
same thing granted
i didn't screw this one up
i think trump would have handled it very
differently but you know
all right let's see rick howell says ian
we didn't see a lot of video during
vietnam there were only three channels
no internet much of the video came out
after the war there was a lot of
self-censorship then too
gore was not the huge draw it is now
okay interesting yeah it's fascinating
okay someone's got the correction for me
i stand corrected bill hughes says they
were not doing jumping jacks they were
being taught how to do the side straddle
hop which is a government jumping jack
huh okay so harder for no reason no but
i'm glad we have the specific uh name
for it
all right weird i think that was a joke
was that a joke no it's side straddle oh
yeah these people they they were trying
to teach them how to do you know side
shuttle hops these people this one guy
he's going like this
like and it's like what are you doing
with your hands like you watched the guy
right
yes
you know look man people who are not
educated and who are impoverished
they're just not gonna be made for this
kind of stuff
all right
martin edgar says look up pictures of
afghanistan in the 70s before the
russian afghan war women wore jeans and
not a burqa to be seen afghanistan has a
close proximity to china
tactically it would have been
advantageous to remain
interesting
matt bowler says tim these people do
have social cohesion and culture
religion however the conflict between
religious groups is so fundamentally
rooted it will seem it will seemingly
forever spur problems
i agree brandon tom says south korea has
been resisting invasion since june 25th
1950 and has been grateful for our help
ever since korea is different and
awesome i certainly i certainly think so
as well i think with korea it was the
it's you know massive force of communism
taking over all these countries and we
said hey don't take over these countries
and then we get involved in these
conflicts though i'm not a fan of what
happened with a lot of i got to say i
got to be honest vietnam awful but uh
for my family like south korea existing
is like a really great thing so i'm
happy about that
i you know i don't i don't live in korea
i'm not from korea but
it wasn't like the russians being like
we're going to test a bunch of our
weapons and us like cool we'll test a
bunch of ours let's use korea to do it
what do you mean like is that what that
war it was a proxy war like were they
just testing weapons and using the
koreans it was the expansion of
communism same as vietnam that's what
they call that's what they said but what
was that was just it was just an arms
rate was vietnam the same thing yeah
pretty much no i think it was the
chinese and the americans using their
weapons communists were spreading across
the asian continent and the us was like
we can ignore this because they're not
our countries but then what happens in
30 years when the communists control all
of asia europe and north africa and then
they're impossible to stop and then they
start cutting off our supplies and then
the u.s falls to these dictators yeah we
have to go now otherwise they grow too
much it's possible and probably even
likely i would say that it was more than
one reason or more than one like
positive outcome that could come out of
it you get to test your weapons and you
get to stop communism
all right let's see uh scallam says
those were ana soldiers then there are
nds and kpf soldiers more skilled but
needed to be babysat to function most
afghans are sheep people the smarter
ones left or leave as soon as they can
yeah they're like farmers right they
just mostly yeah it's
i can't blame them for not knowing how
to fight or being able to understand it
i just think the government like the us
should have realized like hey wait a
minute this isn't going to work well
they get all their their opium and now
they're out did they extract all the
opium or something
yeah what was it that the taliban banned
the opium stuff is that true i don't
know if that's true though they banned
masks is that right i don't know if
that's true they banned some like
critical race theory or something stupid
maybe that's a meme dude i don't know if
that's the problem
dude that's fine all right let's see
well they banned the vaccine i think
dovid benson says how can you expect the
us to teach community identity and
create cultural cohesion to a foreign
entity if we are abolishing those same
values in cohesion in the us the us did
not make an effort to understand the
local tribal cultures to find what would
create cohesion
nor will they do it here in the us when
you get people like you know general
mark milley being like i want to
understand white rage
yeah you'll alienate 92 percent of the
country
but but what he said at the time i don't
think he really wants to understand it
he just said what fits in narrative
because he wants to fit into washing
right and so much of the discussion
these days is just people just going
along with whatever flows
this is a story from uh the week taliban
bands covet 19 vaccine and pacquiao
interesting all right we got uh george
butler says hey tim and crew do you
think potus should send social workers
instead of troops to afghanistan
perhaps good idea and they can teach
people
seven cog says failure to defend taiwan
will be the us's suez canal moment the
point at which the world knows beyond
beyond doubt the us is no longer top dog
and i think it will happen i do you
can't stop it though
i mean you could but the problem is
mark milly
you know i i don't mean him literally
just he's the only problem i mean you
look at the things he says and the way
he behaves and it just shows the
spinelessness the weak mindedness
there's
i'll tell you this i think a large
portion of american leadership has like
almost no mental fortitude and and the
fact that mark milley is
in the position he is just shows that
like
you know the emperor has no clothes it's
weird that that feeling like that we
have too much to lose we don't want to
fight because we don't lose what we have
like we're so elevated above other
people that we don't want to lose our
stuff whereas they don't have that so
they're like i'll fight i got nothing to
lose
so you don't want to get too far ahead
everybody else
justin middleton says tim big fan but i
don't understand this you often quote
edmund burke all that is necessary for
evil to triumph is for good men to do
nothing why doesn't this apply globally
considering your stance on foreign
intervention
i don't think the taliban are going to
be an international cabal that you know
take over the world but that's why i was
saying about the soviet union i
understand why the u.s was doing what it
did and i'm certainly happy that south
korea exists and was defended although
the u.s wasn't able to
defend all of korea
it's tough
a was it was a major failure and uh
we lost there but ultimately the soviet
union fell
i look at afghanistan and i'm like what
are we what are we worried about with
taliban like i understand 9 11 and all
that stuff for sure but that was
specifically targeting a group of people
but that you know that that's a line
that's the line the president said today
like uh technically we could have left
afghanistan 10 15 years ago and if we
can't leave today we can't leave him 15
20 years from now either it's like
what are we trying to accomplish at this
point yeah he said we went after osama
bin laden we got him okay there you go
you know i think what i think what uh
ron paul often said was we shouldn't
have declared war we should have
declared mark in reprisal against the
specific group
and then sought to operate in certain
territories through like you know
agreement yeah i think all in all um
i think that the
the mess up with afghanistan is not so
much going out it's it's i think how
things will play out going forward
i think uh it the the hasty withdrawal
the way it was done is more like an
abandonment and i think this may have
long-term consequences in other words
the deficiency is nothing actually
leaving afghanistan i think people can
understand that
i think uh if the u.s were to leave
afghanistan in some sort of a more
orderly fashion
um you know using the last few months to
do it
and not having these images the last 72
hours
i don't think it would undermine the us
the role of the us in the world
uh so i don't think leaving in itself
is going to be a problem i think how
it's done and and
you know not being able to keep the
government going spending so much money
in the military and uh turning you back
on people who helped you i think those
those things will be a disaster
all right blackrock beacon says trained
afghan commandos while in sf they were
competent also trained regulars and some
older guys who were mujahideen were very
good but many couldn't aim a gun as with
most armies the bulk are the regulars
taliban are mostly seasoned fighters on
par with commandos
that's if that's true that's crazy and
they if they even if that 85 000 guys
were or trained man
yeah i don't know the us wasn't going to
be able to hold that
all right let's see
ah here's a very very important chat
working rage-aholic says
oy tim can you talk about yuri besmanov
dude warned us years ago about what was
going to happen but no one listened oh
you ever see that yuri besnoff video
yeah yeah ian yes oh yeah oh yeah we
should make everyone watch it every day
if you've ever seen that have you been
asked about that video 25 times you know
you know we have you know we have the uh
the thing that appears on the screen
says like share this
you know like this you know subscribe we
should make another one where it just
says yes we've seen the yuri basmati
video yes
just included in it is still kicking is
he alive still he was old and then
i don't know but i appreciate all the
super chats of people constantly
bringing him up because he was warning
us and when people bring it up and we
get to say it more people will learn
about yeah he told us about how the long
game basically the communist long game
of like they get into your culture and
then they start seeding descent for 20
years and then they so we're kind of he
was telling us about this in the 90s and
saying it's happening right now he's
right
mussy moose says i urge everyone watch a
video on youtube titled mass psychosis
how an entire population becomes
mentally ill they talk about a killing
of the mind modern day totalitarian and
how parallel systems can be used to
defeat it i've seen that video it is
really really good and it is incredibly
well done it is called mass psychosis
how an entire population becomes
mentally ill you got to check it out you
should we should watch it it it
basically talks about
you i'll just leave it there thanks
watch it and you'll be like hmm this
sounds familiar oh boy
oh yeah and it's like a a a big channel
doing an educational video like talking
philosophy uh you have to look it up i
don't know okay
all right
adjaden says shout out to ojpak yasi's
non-profit org
oh yeah do you have you have a
non-profit yeah yeah what is it what do
you do our mission is to fight bigotry
against the orthodox jewish community
and to advocate for civil rights civil
liberties that affect our community for
example last year we
pushed a lot of data and advocacy in
terms of restoring patient rights and
hospitals
i think not i think until today most
hospitals do not have a regular
visitation restored due to coronavirus
and i think it's important for people
who who believe in family values
to have the ability to visit family
members it's very important for their
recovery so we educated on that front we
also pushed a lot of advocacy to open
schools
last year
in new york
because again
unlike
most of the us i think like only 21 of
the us population is under the age of
18. in our community it's 60 percent oh
can you believe it wow it's it's it's uh
you know three fifths it's huge so uh
when you you didn't have school for a
week you can imagine how parents and
families are going crazy
and how important school is it's not all
you know you have a child here and there
you have like the more than half of the
population is stuck in time
so you know those are things and also we
were
one of the lawsuits that were brought
against como to uh
permit people to go to synagogues the
congregations was something that we
helped coordinate uh you know that
lawsuit ultimately was sidelined because
two other lawsuits from i think um
uh the catholics in brooklyn also from a
other major orthodox organization
advanced to the supreme court so this
lawsuit didn't take off but we were busy
you know on the front so that's where we
would uh you know advocate a lot
on on these issues and then on the
defensive front i think uh
como for a time for a while last fall
and also bill de blasio they made in new
york city
they had a disproportionate focus on
orthodox jews as a community
by skewing coronavirus data points and
we pushed back with press releases
articles tv appearances stories and
numbers you know to keep the
conversation going i think
any growing community
especially community that stands out i
mean you walk in the streets somebody's
orthodox jewish you can see it i think
it's important to get information out
there either in a proactive or a
reactive fashion and we try to try doing
that right on between the tweets all
right
emily mower says his name for a book by
the way did ian just say rights are
given the government does not grant us
our rights the constitution protects our
rights that we inherently have from the
government lol yeah yeah yeah that's
what we tell ourselves the myth of our
time come on it's it's enforced by law
what do you mean all our rights that we
say are god given come on that's not you
are a product of your society our
society is built to protect those rights
that we gave ourselves
what do you mean
the united is a self-fulfilling prophecy
we accidentally have all these rights
you know we had to choose to create
these for ourselves he's saying
interesting point he's saying that you
need to have a government
that agrees to protect your rights if
not those rights are taken away by
government so it's
oh interesting
but i guess
yeah or by a giant bear or whatever yeah
whatever but i think their rights
the rights are not given by government
you know that's why it's called uh i
think negative rights it's not
government gives you
the government doesn't you know you're
you you are protected from government
taking it away but that means government
is willing not to take it away so we're
still governed by law
um
way deeper i think yeah that's a whole
conversation you're getting semantic
again ian
she's saying that we we all have these
rights like i as an individual believe
these rights are mine and you can't take
them you can try fortunately we have a
bill of rights in this country that
protects the rights that i believe i
have and always had
and i do think the government infringes
on those rights the government doesn't
grant them to us we have them the
government just breaks the rules and
tries to take them from us all the time
and they do yeah all right let's see
the last of my kinds is on my birthday i
told y'all how i was 31 walking with a
cane last week took ian's advice and got
some collagen thanks bio trust keep it
up ship nice whoa whoa [ __ ] dude check
out um what is it los ange it's a socal
chiropractic ace there man this this
like 70 year old man came in bent over
on a walker and he
cracked his neck helped him stand up
straight and the dudes off the walker
interesting
you can do it too
woot do for you says i have counted
tim's exasperated size at ian's answers
it's over nine thousand
love you ian but sometimes you make me
bash my skull against a british i'm here
baby
love you too
all right andrew essays this one made me
a fan of yossi great guest absolutely
all right we'll just do that
so so you're the one okay
we'll just grab uh we'll grab one more
very important garhent says ian is to
the left of stalin someone have ian to
the political compass online it'll be
funny to see the look on his face when
he realizes he's a
commie opposition let's we can do this
all right everybody if you haven't
already give a give a like a tap to that
little like button subscribe to this
channel share share the show with your
friends if you really like it leave us a
good review leave some comments and go
to timcast.com become a member because
there will be a members only segment
coming up uh it usually goes live around
11 or so p.m so you'll definitely want
to check that one out they're always
more fun we've had a lot of people say
can we make the members only show the
main show and i'm like i guess the
problem is we'd get banned yeah
immediately i don't think we say
anything that crazy but we're allowed to
actually say like here's what youtube
would ban us for if we were gonna have
this conversation so we try to have them
there
i guess it kind of sucks in a lot of
ways but we're growing the business and
we've got a lot of stuff on the way
someone super chatted that i said tales
of intrigue that is not the name of the
show that would be very generic weird
i'm just that's generally it because
shane who's uh writing all this stuff he
wrote like a mafia murder mystery cold
case which is really awesome and so
we're turning you know his articles into
a show and then we're going to have
his story and then followed by someone
from the house like hanging out and
talking about the stuff so it'd be
really cool like when he talks about
some when he writes up like dmt or
whatever ian will be you know have a
conversation with him and that'll be a
members only podcast so definitely
become a member at timcast.com is there
anything you want to shout out yossi
before we go i just want to give you a
thanks uh for giving me the opportunity
to appear on your show and i want to
give a shout out to you i think uh some
how old are you 36 35 35 okay so young
adam you would hear a change i think it
takes a lot of um
um
energy and you know will to do what you
do
and you know to go along with the
program i'm not saying you're a
contrarian just for the fun of it but
you have your thoughts you have your
opinions and you share it you share it
in a
in an interesting way you bring in
guests you know to to challenge and you
challenge your semi co-host there you
know i think you guys i thought you guys
were going to blow i would out i
restrained myself yeah apparently so so
i think you know to run a business and
and and to start a business especially
in the commentary world i think it takes
a lot of guts especially that
you never know uh when haters would try
to pile on and then try to
but pile on in a destructive way and try
to you know
the platform and destroy you so
i think this you know having the
opportunity to speak to your audience is
what made me uh take this drive more
than four hours thank you for doing that
so yeah it's not like i walked in there
from i was in the neighborhood it's a
driver four hours plus stops uh you know
each way
um and also i wanted one i wanted to
have the ability to strengthen what you
do i appreciate it man i think we we
spoke of the show a lot of times people
like to say um
you know cancer culture you know is bad
okay so if cancer culture is bad
you should be out there and
conversing with people who are not part
of the machine people who are out there
who made who others may try to cancel
them i'm not saying he's a pariah but
i'm just trying to get a point across
that
from a business perspective and from a
policy perspective and from
accomplishment perspective what tim is
doing is amazing i appreciate it yeah
thanks man and it's it's a benefit for
me of being able to be here and i wanted
to join your show
uh no matter the the time that it takes
because i think you're doing amazing
work you got a twitter account yeah i do
have a twitter account which is at
y-o-s-s-i gestetna it's yasi gestating
y-o-s-i guess that i don't know why tim
and i we don't follow each other
we used to follow we unfollowed i don't
know i never unfollowed i i get
unfollowed from people all the time yeah
so yeah but um the brian you know ron
coleman of course i've been unfollowed
from him like four times so ron and when
i said before that um we we tried to
push a
lawsuit iran was the attorney on that
lawsuit
and i arranged at the time a major press
conference major not national tv but uh
regionally we had all the tv channels
there yeah i know ram very well and he
was actually honored at our event our we
have an annual dinner
and he was honored this year for his uh
for his work for the orthodox community
right now but yeah so um cool man so
that's that i appreciate it appreciate
the time it's it's good to know you ian
and i appreciate the
inquisitor questions before the show
it's interesting oh yeah we're talking
about religion talking about judaism
is it has sadism is how you acidicism
has
is the people of cynicism is the way of
we're going to maybe life
into it a little bit on the afternoon
we'll get into it pretty cool and don't
forget to follow the show at tim cast
irl
on every platform or whatever and you
can follow me at tim cast and yeah i'm
at ian crossland ian crossland.net love
you and you guys may follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids and i really
appreciate yasi driving all the way down
here and i'm excited for the after show
because we are going to talk about his
faith that's right we love talking about
religion and stuff because it's uh you
know just the big questions so make sure
you go to timcast.com be a member and we
will see you all there bye guys
you